lean in dramatically more to things that
are positive your grandfather podcasts
lean into positivity then eyes wide open
and is this delusional and lacks
practicality like you know if I just
dream it it will happen no lean in cut
out literally when this podcast is over
step back audit your entire life from
the people you spend time with your
family your friends look at every person
you follow are they triggering your
insecurities for their own self-interest
are they trying to put love into it so
that you go on and do your thing watch
look for it oh whatever you do cut out
one hour of negativity add one hour of
positivity if you're listening right now
and you're like Ugh social's such a drag
it's because you're in a drag mindset
and the Algos and the people you follow
are following you you know what my
social looks like in sunshine I'm being
dead serious you know what my Algos look
like
sunshine in the world of the momentum of
Darkness right now sunshine you know why
I choose to fight for positive but I
refuse to not be grounded in
practicality which is why I've always
thrown curveballs 8th Place trophies
lead to entitlement and fear of losing
and if it's up kids so like it's kind of
that juxtaposition practical positivity
is something everyone needs to add more
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need it I need it
for me because I don't wake up every day
and say yes let's go conquer the world
now I wake up and and I need that
external motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Gary vaynerchuk enjoy
my life is happy because I think
everything in my life is my fault all of
it
it is the most liberating truth of all
time of course I'm logically
understanding that there's other people
that there's other variables that
there's things I don't control but I'm
completely in control to what I do you
are capable of doing anything you are
capable of firing your employees you are
capable of breaking up in your
relationship you are capable of moving
to another town another country you are
capable of selling your home and
downgrading your home to a smaller home
so you're always not tight on money you
are capable of all of it
but we don't like that we like
to blame all our problems
on Putin
[Applause]
bad day at work Putin
bad day at home
Facebook the algorithm and the dictators
are not impacting your day-to-day
anywhere close to what you've decided
your lack of accountability is dictating
this is a very
focal point of the conversation
we must understand this
everything you talk about
gratitude empathy kindness all things
that I live on they all come from me
thinking everything's my fault
they all come from me knowing I have
control everybody when they get into the
accountability and control game
immediately much of this audience starts
thinking to the Counterpoint
they immediately start thinking to the
Counterpoint
the natural human spirit for most people
when told everything is your fault you
are in control of everything will start
giving you 800 answers to why that's not
true for them
and that's how they're missing the point
when I brought up earlier sell if you
are tight on money
and you own a home sell your home and
live in a your home
do you know how many people do that on
Earth no one
do you know how logical what I just said
is you were tight on cash you were
really struggling you own a fairly nice
home and your mortgage situation you
have an asset
and you will not sell it to live in a
lesser home
because you worry about what people
think about that move
my favorite chess move to this debate is
like but Gary I can't do that to my kids
my Counterpoint is that's the best you
can do for your kids failures are
personal they're not public meaning
when I fail I have the enjoyment of
Leaning into my addiction of humility
and I love that I've learned and I don't
have to make those same pattern mistakes
in the future so I double win I get
another dose of humility which I achieve
for and strive for and I get a learning
that I'm smart enough and capable enough
of not repeating the reason people are
scared of failure is because they worry
about people's opinions on the outside
their parents their siblings and the
general public Anonymous people on
Twitter and Discord and the world which
is silly because the reality is it's
your life and what you really learn is
you've gotta the reason people are
scared of of failure is because they
have egos they actually think that their
life is that important that people's
Judgment of their failures is important
I know even with my significance of
awareness and popularity success
notoriety that at the end of the day I'm
just one little speck of eight billion
people on Earth during a little 100 Year
window on the universe's trajectory of
all time and so I I'm humbled by that
and thus when I fail that's me with
myself and that has nothing to do with
any of you has nothing to do with any of
you let alone the people closest to me
it has nothing to do with them all of a
sudden once failure becomes an insular
game not an external game failure does
not become scary it actually becomes
interesting for some of us me included
go go is the happiness
I try to tell a lot of friends like Gary
you need to pick up golf I'm like [__]
off I don't like calls like I'm pop you
love golf and the fact that for four
hours that's your escapism for me my
hobby my hobby is business
so for the same way people like skiing
and cooking and golf like for some of us
in this room the go go is the happiness
the reason if you pick up the context of
what I just talked about the reason I've
always done what I've done is because I
love it
when I'm when you're nine and it snows
and you don't want to make a snowman and
go sledding but you want to ring
doorbells and shovel snow like that's
just in you and so for me first for the
people that are Partners or have loved
ones that go go don't eliminate the com
the thought that maybe
that's just their great love that the
work is their hobby that exists I'm one
of those people on the flip side
I've watched too many friends and
contemporaries burn out if you die
your business is closed anyway
like if you don't like it this is a very
simple thing for me everything works
because I love it
but if you don't like it and you're
doing it for the money you're indeed
it's not sustainable you are vulnerable
it won't work it may work for six years
it may work for nine years but it won't
work
I also think like as we go through our
Journeys you know for me to your point
from 2009
as if you remember it was similar to
what I think we might be walking into we
had the 2008 crash nobody knew the
internet think about what I'm talking
about here today when I was talking
about that in 2008 saying you can make
money on YouTube people laughed at me so
I was very passionate to be like hey I
know you lost your job but it's not the
end of the world you can go hard you can
get a lower paying job during the day
and if you want to get out of it you can
do something you love from 7 P.M to
midnight also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there there's two ways to be Uber
successful deep confidence deep security
my happiness is completely based on
Simplicity are the 12 people that I'm
most infatuated with and love with
healthy
[Music]
I'm driven by the Gratitude of my
perspective and I do want to scale it
[Music]
all of my happiness is predicated on my
humility I don't think I'm special I try
to be great but deep down I don't have
to keep up a facade
content
happy I have ahis all of those three
things are way better than a verified
account with tens of millions of
followers way better than tens of
millions of dollars in a bank account
way better than any of that
thank you this concept that we're like
trying to like get validation from
others is really hurting people
I'm trying my best my intent is there
some things are going to work and some
things aren't
I'm completely convinced that there's so
much more happiness and simplicity once
you fall in love with humility you have
a chance of being happy yeah and so you
know humility is not at the expense of
confidence
and ambition I'm all sorts of confident
and ambitious
I also have the humility to realize I'm
not special I also have the humility and
this and the self-confidence to not need
outside affirmation
and so you know when I hear you start
this conversation in the context of
mortgage professionals who made a ton of
money and right now aren't like I don't
I struggle with
the heavy negativity being a financial
situation yeah because if you crushed
the last two years you seemingly have
the opportunity
to eat a lot of Humble Pie and reset
including well Gary I didn't buy a house
yeah and so I can't down trade I bought
a lot of stuff absolutely sell your
stuff like if you bought an 8 000
handbag that in hindsight you wish you
had eight thousand sell it for 6 700 on
eBay yep
people want their cake and eat it too
and that's why they have issues I say
Lean Into You Know accountability yeah
and address the situation what are your
thoughts in the economy right now and
how an ambitious business owner should
navigate that especially a contractor
yeah I'm not a economist so I'm not I'm
coming from a complete guess what do I
feel I feel that
there's just a lot of instability in the
world right there's there's war in
Europe there's
a huge shift in the way the world
communicates between social and
traditional media there's clearly uh
East versus West scenario between China
and America that continues to get more
strategic
if not contentious you know you've got
alliances bricks right Brazil Russia
India China South Africa
is a real economic Alliance now that is
something that the U.S and
Europe can't ignore that leads to like
different actions different
instabilities
um I think that there is incredible lack
of people saving money you know the
coolness of saving money of the 50s and
60s has become not cool people live on
credit
people buy things they can't afford
so that's always scary I would say an
ambitious small business should make
sure that they have a just in case fund
so like don't overextend yourself be
sitting on cash to the best of your
ability
a little a little Nest Egg but don't be
frozen by fear like be on the offense if
you're good like if you're good you'll
pick up business during tough times
because your competitors will lose their
business to you I think people should
listen to everything and try to find
positivity and usability out of
everything and they should dismiss what
is clearly negative and selfish and they
should triple down on everything that is
selfless and positive and that is the
answer to your question that started
here what should people do they should
be very very focused on trying to do the
following lean in dramatically more to
things that are positive your
grandfather
podcasts
upworthy.com lean into positivity then
they should be on the awareness Eyes
Wide Open on is this delusional and
lacks practicality like you know if I
just dream it it will happen no
lean in cut out literally when this
podcast is over step back audit your
entire life
from the people you spend time with your
family your friends look at every person
you follow are they triggering your
insecurities for their own self-interest
are they trying to put love into it so
that you go on and do your thing watch
look for it but whatever you do
back to like working out like you know
protein and you know when I when you
know when Mike vacant is like all right
you did a left like protein I'm like
really okay and like during code I'm
like wait a minute I'm starting to
finally get some muscles oh because I
was doing protein as [__] after lifts
and not after not lifts I was doing it
right here's something right for
everyone cut out one hour of negativity
add one hour of positivity
if you're listening right now and you're
like uh social's such a drag it's
because you're in a drag mindset and the
Algos and the people you follow are
following you you know what my social
looks like
sunshine
I'm being dead serious you know my Algos
look like
sunshine in the world of the momentum of
Darkness right now sunshine you know why
I choose to fight
for positivity but I refuse to not be
grounded in practicality which is why
I've always thrown curveballs love
everybody it's all awesome Faith Place
trophies what Gary what what eighth
place trophies lead to entitlement and
fear of losing and if it's up kids
so like it's kind of that juxtaposition
practical positivity is something
everyone needs to add more my biggest
concern is that I know there's a lot of
people here consume my content leave
comments DM me engage
they talk my talk but they don't live my
talk
I get more emails from people that are
the employees of people who love me and
talk about me all day
to tell me that Rick loves you I have no
idea what you're talking about but
Rick's completely full of [__]
he talks like you talk he repeats your
sh but he's a [__]
that Rick story is super common
I know there's a ton of Ricks in this
room right now I know it more than the
sun will come up tomorrow you talk that
garyvee you don't live that garyvee
and where you don't live it is not on
the hustle and grind you don't live it
on the kindness and Humanity you don't
live it on the empathy and about that
100 percent
and I don't say that on stage to come up
here and like I'm good and scolding you
I'm coming on stage saying cut that [__]
out I promise you if you listen to this
it's real
the reason I pound patients down
everyone's throat and everyone hates the
flavor of it
is because once you have a framework of
patience it eliminates so much bad
behavior
patience is important because most
people can't see
like the way I set up this talk can't
see that most of the [__] they do is for
affirmation from other people
people can't see that most of the they
do is to get credit from other people
normally toxic relationships whether
parents siblings plus ones or my
favorite thing to hate because I hate
the word hate but I hate this
so many of you live your life
based on the comments from strangers on
social media
people here don't post certain because
they don't think it's going to get
enough likes
people post certain that they're not
even about anymore because they think
it's going to get a bunch of likes
people are scared to make video content
when they know video content works
because they're scared the way they look
and they don't want people to say they
don't look good
the world runs on a currency of people
trying to get affirmation from others
people buy they can't afford they don't
want to do all to impress people they
don't even like recession what is your
take on it turn fear into common sense
and practicality and humility and
everything will be Beyond okay
let me say that nice and slow so
everyone understands you should be
fearful things are happening
Apple doesn't shut down production of
iPhones for its health Banks don't do
what they are doing right now which is
clamping the
down right VCS don't stress even though
they got tons of dollars to deploy
they're smart what are they gonna just
write a check at a higher valuation when
they know the Market's going to be
different in six months this is real
this is the time to not waste money as a
company or as a human being maybe you
don't need Starbucks every day maybe you
shouldn't order from Postmates every day
maybe you should cook in your little
apartment maybe you don't need to take
an Uber maybe you don't need to do these
things like me you definitely don't need
to be buying
that you don't need you don't need to
upgrade your car you may not need a
bigger television you may not need 17
employees maybe it's 11. it's
devastating because you don't want bad
for those six people but like you if you
go out of business then all 17 people
are out of business right so
don't take it as fear it's just real
life
actually realize the last 10 years you
should have been grateful for and you
should add gratitude for how easy it was
covet wasn't hard covet was easy the
government printed an unlimited amount
of money why do you think we're here I
love how people like it's their fault
it's not their fault who printed all the
money we printed all the money like I
don't understand like how people
understand like there's nothing common
sense or natural about I'm gonna sit at
home and the government's going to pay
me more to sit at home than have an
actual job it sounded all fun but the
problem was people bought Dom p and
Playstation fives with that money like
don't you understand people are confused
out here they're living insecure and
they need stuff to patch up their
insecurity or to flex in front of others
life is about self-esteem period end of
story and so what do I think I think
everyone should be very thoughtful about
every dollar they have now look I I have
lots of savings so I don't have to
change anything I can not do anything
for seven years different so I'm less
worried but if I could if I had to
change my lifestyle I would immediately
and I'm Gonna Change My Lifestyle
because there's gonna be opportunities
and I'd rather buy a business during
this time than have another extra fancy
dinner like people need to get the smart
be practical like I don't know what you
think is going to happen don't [__]
hope and don't ask the government to do
something for you like do it for
yourself the amount of times I see
kids like yourselves roll up on me and
say Gary I'm gonna buy the Chicago Bulls
you're gonna buy the Jets I'm gonna buy
the Bulls and I can taste it
in their sentence that they know they
can't
the place where it really works is when
you stop peacocking and posturing to
yourself
as a measure to make yourself feel
better
and bigger
and actually are just comfortable with
what you are you get really into your
state this is what's so great about my
life you're a failure you're going to be
a garbage man and I was just like I just
like selling stuff you know and I don't
care that everybody thinks that I'm not
a lawyer or a doctor
or an executive like I'm happy and if
that makes you know I was a pig at 27
making 70 000 a year pumped working
every day at a liquor store helping my
family like
flows easy Once you stop lying to
yourself and want and once you stop
trying to impress others with the [__]
that comes out of your mouth when you
die
you'll be dead for a very long time
are you sure
I'd love listen if this whole thing
about souls go into like I would love to
come back as a little Danish girl
um but
yes when you die
you will be dead for a long time
also I don't know if you know this
you were not born
for a very long time
we have like even though life is long
and hopefully everybody here lives to at
least a hundred
it's also if you take a step up very
short
the concept of not squeezing the [__]
out of it
from a happiness
standpoint from a trying standpoint from
an ambitious standpoint is ludicrous to
me and so I keep it super simple nobody
died best day ever
[Music]
I mean it I mean it
to the negative people in my life
there's been some of my friends and
family that are negative that there's
two times in my life where I actually
said this I got so frustrated to a
family member so frustrated so upset I
literally told them because they were
so upset about the dumbest in the world
I literally told them that I wished
something atrocious happened to them the
next day
just for perspective
we just lack perspective
Like We complain about ludicrous things
the amount of people that are
entrepreneurs that were not built for
school that have gone on too successful
but more importantly happy lives that
have far more college-educated student
I'm literally almost everybody that
works for my companies the 1500 current
employees and the tens of thousands that
have worked for me in my life literally
almost all of them outside of a couple
Scrappers at Wine Library stock boys
have been on paper more educated than me
forget about my financial success in
comparison to the majority of them
it's the sheer happiness of living
what's in your DNA that is so important
yeah I view entrepreneurship like I view
art I really do I really do I believe
that artists who are truly artists are
happy to live by Financial humble means
to be able to draw or to Doodle or
whatever they do and if that means
they'll make 60 63 000 a year scrapping
by a side job and selling a couple of
paintings that if they truly are a true
artist not one who thought they wanted
to be an artist to become Banksy or make
money or be famous or be a rock star and
date models I mean truly
I am an artist and I love it I believe
they're happier than than a you know
chemical engineer making eight hundred
thousand dollars a year and I think I
think that's why I associate with
entrepreneurship so much more about the
freedom of being happy about doing your
true Mission than the financial success
that's associated with it
because when I got into it
it wasn't cool like it is nothing
matters more than understanding where
the actual attention is versus where the
perceived attention is
and the perceived attention is usually
garnered by the icons and leaders of the
world the establishment
where they want to see it right
um
Sports I'll give you a great one sports
team owners
want to see television commercials to
feel like their league is relevant right
now yeah it was relevant to them when
they were kids
the 65 to 80 year old
the 58 to 80 year old current Sports
owner from the English Premier League to
the NHL NFL NBA MLB and everything in
between want to see Billboards and
television spots to feel as if they're
communicating their sport
while
90 of Their audience is consuming it
here yeah
that is perceived attention is on
billboards and television versus actual
attention is on Tick Tock and Twitter
and Spotify and Netflix right yep that
is the only thing that matters if you're
trying to grow and it's the most
dangerous thing
if you're declining without realizing it
people have just not made the commitment
to realizing brand is actually built in
social social by Nature allows you to
create more creative when you're able to
create more creative you're able to
focus on relevance not just awareness
I believe every Fortune 500 brand does
not have an awareness issue that's why
they're a Fortune 500 brand they have a
relevance issue how do you make Nike
matter to every single person how do you
make apple BMW product how do you make
it actually matter the way you make it
matter is by storytelling the way you
make it matter is that story has to hit
you me you Dustin Meadow we have
different things that are going to make
us interested social is conducive to
that kind of output plus we now live in
a world where the algorithms are
rewarding content that is interesting to
people that by Nature creates consumer
insights consumer insights are the
starting point to do great work right if
you know something about what people are
already interested in you have a better
chance of making something that they're
interested in thus rendering them to do
the thing you want them to do and in the
context of this it means to buy
something so you know I think the brands
of the Middle East and the world need to
make a bigger commitment to Output more
volume more platform strategy more
creative strategy more cultural strategy
we call it packed platforms and culture
and I and I think the faster they do
that the more likely they'll gain market
share
um and I think every brand has to go
through that Journey the world is
struggling to find its way with hard
work because the world is doing a good
job of being thoughtful about burnout I
love that
I love that I use the word worth I love
that I use the word work ethic now
instead of the word Hustle
not because of anything else but if the
world has taken the word hustle and
changed it on me which is what happened
when I used hustle it just meant you've
got to give effort yeah it didn't mean
getting yourself into depression and
don't sleep and use drugs to cope that's
not how I Define it that is how the
world defines it I am thrilled to adjust
my word
but the world is struggling with the
word work ethic
it just is
and so what ends up happening is parents
are struggling to find that balance yes
you can be better at everything in the
world there's not one thing in the world
that I don't think I can be better at
not one skiing teaching
punching eating there's everything I can
be better at I can't be world class at
everything that is something the world's
gonna have to get better at
honey you could be anything you want in
the world with no honey you can maximize
your natural talents in every category
if you put a lot of work ethic into it
you just might not be Beyonce and LeBron
and that's awesome but like for example
I love basketball
could be way better I could tomorrow
hire a new shooting coach I'm wealthy
now I can hire a shooting coach can come
to my apartment even every day of the
week I can get up at 6am I can be better
than my brother even though he's better
than me now if I really went hard for
the next five years and worked on my
game uh but I'm not gonna be in the NBA
and we've got to find that place with
our I do with my employees I do with my
employees I do it with my family I do
with everybody in the world through
content because it it leads to a better
place but then there's such a fine line
between you helping and you being a
Dream Crusher correct but a Dream
Crusher is based on delusion like again
it's a very simple sentence that I'm
going to be ex cool anything that isn't
physical
I would argue is in play if somebody's I
think it's much easier to be the
president of the United States of
America than it is to be an NBA player I
think it's much easier to be famous on
television than it is to be a to be an
NBA player I think it's much easier to
be the greatest Chef in the world than
it is to be an NBA player I think where
crushing dreams has to come in is a
little bit you know based on realities
of physical stuff
right you know I just think that's real
and a lot of people gravitate towards
physical stuff early on but if somebody
says they're gonna be an astronaut
everybody's in play for an astronaut now
if you're like my mom and everything
makes you nauseous
you know one could argue you have more
hurdles to get over
you know to become an astronaut but I
still think you can get over the hump on
nausea I did by the way on the record in
my youth I struggled with flights and I
would get my tummy would hurt I threw up
on flights in my teenage years now I
take flights every hour of the day so I
got better Heights I'm better like I'll
live high now at my office eye like you
know like so you can get better at
things the number one thing I've
recognized in the last 25 years of
managing people
about high performers is their North
Stars change
so a 24 year old who's come in here two
years in and completely dominated May
sit down with me and she may tell me
that she's going to be the CEO of the
whole company one day and I get excited
I go good because I'm old and I can't
wait for someone to take over
and we laugh
sometimes that 24 year old at 29
finds their life partner
and all of a sudden she and he's not in
the office 15 hours a day every day
and they're not going down the path of
becoming the CEO anymore and I'm very
conscious of that first of all don't
forget what I said High touch so I'm
paying attention
and neither I if they sit on it too long
or they tend to bring up like hey you
know I think I need a little more
work-life balance and I'm like Mazel Tov
amazing
I I don't need you to be the CEO you
wanted to be the CEO you're gonna work
your face off let there be no confusion
there is no other way
and back to the earlier question that's
too big of a price for some people with
family others figure out how to manage
it and everything in between everyone
has their own situation but
the the realities with high performers
is allowing them room to change their
mind number three
understanding the balance between praise
and truth and candor
a lot of times people are concerned are
over complementary of high performers or
disproportionately under complementary
depending on what strategy they're
deploying
many people
try to pick at the shortcomings of their
High performers to keep them in line
others try to over verbalize to keep
them in line because they give them
positive reinforcements but they can't
afford maybe the financial or the title
things that the person's answer and the
truth is you've got to find the middle
it's got to be based on the actual truth
and people struggle with that because
they're using one or two or both sides
of the equation of what I just said so
for me it's
a lack of fear of losing them
it's a you know it's a deep
commitment to an actual relationship
above and beyond the professional one
it's
over communicating with them when you're
not going to deliver on what they want
Gary I need to be a senior vice
president this next race cycle
let me sleep on it three weeks later hey
I think it's gonna be an extra cycle and
here's why and I always say this hey I'm
making a subjective decision I might be
wrong
I'm in the unfortunate position to have
to make that subjective decision
and you have a Humanity Humanity
Humanity
humanity is missing how do you assign
value what is value when it comes to
determining
that perceived value from a consumer's
perspective of any particular piece of
Ip that you have whether it's to be
friends whether it's you know this NBA
All-Stars it's the only thing I think
about like your Puma socks like
literally I already I saw I I like when
we were just I saw it you had Puma socks
and I my brain goes to those are 37 Cent
socks
yeah that he paid nine bucks for because
it has four letters in the same order
with the same logo and it means
something
so you know for me that's just how the
entire world works
this
is a bottle of water this was free
for a drillion years and then somewhere
about 50 years ago someone's like wait a
minute I'm gonna sell something that is
actually free
and if I can make the brand mean
something
people will actually pay a lot of money
for something that to remind everybody
water was free and every faucet and so I
think it's the only thing I think it's
how monarchies or capitalism or
democracy or communism or dictator's
work I think it's how people parent all
I think about is IP you know all I think
about is comms and marketing and how
things work and and then and then for me
specifically in the journey I'm on
my driver for building out my IP
selfishly is about oh I think I can
build a big business
selflessly
um I think about if I can create 300
characters in a Pokemon Sesame Street
Marvel like world where I can do what
I've done for 15 years as garyvee and
pushed kindness patience empathy
well that's been hard
you know garyvee is a very specific
human being who's gonna work for some
people it's not going to work for others
but this patient Panda might be more
effective of teaching people patience
than me
and so for me I'm really enjoying the
building out of the intellectual
property and I want to really leave a
legacy I'm very very affected as I
become more educated on how Jim Henson
saw the world nobody here today in 2023
is confused that human beings attention
sits on social media at scale
everybody here has an opinion of that
unfortunately many people here deploy
their human opinion their feelings about
Tick Tock in China or Facebook and zucks
or that their kids are on it too long
you deploy your subjective human opinion
as a human on it when thinking about
your actual business the consumer you're
trying to reach to sell your service to
is really not super interested on your
hot take of what 13 year olds are doing
on Tick Tock they're not super intrigued
by how much you like or dislike Facebook
they just live their life
see things and spend their money I want
every person's room after this
conference to go home tomorrow and post
somewhere between 8 and 15 pieces of
content on LinkedIn YouTube Shorts
Facebook Instagram snap Tick Tock and I
want you to do it every day I know
that nobody wants to do that I know this
because I watch the world
this is clear what I just said is a
hundred percent it's non-debatable fact
that the people that are outflanking in
every micro segment of every business in
the output of creative and of course the
quality matters
of course the quality of what comes out
of your mouth is a variable of your
success
before you even start the debate of what
do you say or what are you talking about
or how are you doing this the data is
undeniable that the companies and humans
in service businesses that are
outposting its competitive set are
picking up market share by the simple
fact of there's just too much attention
of society on these seven to ten
platforms there are people in this room
that will do one video of here's a fun
fact of the opportunities in mortgages
post that on Instagram reels and Tick
Tock and it with no followers you do not
have an account yet and it's your
seventh video and one video like that
may go viral and lead to more leads for
you in a 24-hour window then you would
get the entire year
that happens every day
yet we continue to choose not to look
there's way too much deciding on
subjective opinion in this room and it's
not about this room it's the whole world
the reason I can say it is I see the
data across the whole world this is
what's happening this is why there's a
supply and demand opportunity life is
very simple it's supply and demand
it's actually shockingly simple if you
understand supply and demand in every
aspect about everything about life you
will start to understand how to make
decisions very simply the thing that I
want to compel this room to is to
understand the single biggest
opportunity of under Supply not enough
posts against demand too much
consumption is leading to remarkable
opportunity so it's just classic right
like every single person here knows how
to get into better shape everyone
there's not a person in this room that
does not understand that it is a
combination of eating better and going
to the gym yet I think we can all agree
not everyone in this room is doing that
I struggle with that for 40 years 38
years I never wanted to either and then
I just one day on a plane decided this
is not going to end up well and I
started working on it nine years later
eight years later I still never want to
do it a single day I literally hired a
full-time human being to be my
babysitter and travel I'm being dead
serious I got to the financial level
where I could I finally figured it out
I'm very good at being accountable to
others just because it comes natural to
me to do 10 posts a day
I know that for 80 of this room it does
not
but just like the journey I went on
which is I didn't want to die at 65. I
thought it would be better to live
longer I like it
I'm doing something every day for nine
straight years that I genuinely
genuinely hate and so I don't care how
much you hate social media I don't care
that you've decided it's ruined the
world and the kids and the this and the
that and I do genuinely don't care
because your customer doesn't care
it doesn't care what you think of it I
just desperately need you to stop losing
market share
because if you're not going to do it
somebody else is and those referrals are
great and they'll keep you going but I
don't have to explain to anybody here
that if you don't get more it's
eventually going to run out World let me
explain to you for everyone who's like
these platforms make all the money and
they're using me and I'm getting used
let's just talk about it
Dustin
do you know if it does cost or does not
cost money
to put an ad in a newspaper do you think
you can call a newspaper and say hey I'd
like you to put a full page ad and
here's what I'd like you to put and I'd
prefer you charge me nothing
that is not possible Right do you think
I can call CNN right now and say hey CNN
hey Fox hey CBS hey ABC I would like to
run a video in between your hit shows
a commercial and I would like to pay you
nothing for that
okay that billboard outside right behind
you do you think I can call that number
and say hey I'd like to put up the vinyl
that goes there to say follow V friends
on social media and please charge me
nothing
do you believe I can call Howard Stern's
Show on Sirius and say Hey Howard listen
you know how you do read these things in
between the show and you're like go to
befriends.com to do you think Howard
would do that for free
cool now
these social networks say hey we're open
create an account
post something and something can happen
and it costs zero
from us this whole concept that these
social networks have the man the man has
used social networks for their benefit
I've built a humongous audience on
YouTube Facebook Twitter Instagram Tick
Tock Snapchat and I haven't paid those
companies a single penny
and when I sell empathy and empathy and
all this like that where does that come
from
this is a ludicrous conversation
I can't wait for decentralized social
networks where you have to build your
own audience
where you're not maybe I guess not
relying on an algorithm to you post and
people are there you're getting access
to people
people love to cry about things that
they take for granted
I when I was older I was like wait a
minute what
will not be charged
Twitter wait so let me get this right
this is why I freaked out about Twitter
back to buying stuff like so
I get to post
people follow me and they can share what
I so I get word of mouth and
distribution and the platform's not
charging me
and by the way here it comes
Twitter's about to charge for no like
and everyone's and you know what
everyone's gonna do this [__] why do
we chart because you don't you don't
want ads you don't want them to monetize
like this
uh my data is being monetized is [__]
lap by the way on the record
I'd be really sad if that went away I
like that most of the ads that I see
have something of interest for me
I don't like the ads on television I
don't need diapers or tampons when I'm
watching this like I don't need it I
don't need your beer I'm not gonna drink
your beer I don't need that ad I like
New York Jets ads
it's a better experience when I'm
targeted the whole thing is
it really does not because I love social
now I don't give a [__] about I could
give a [__]
about social networks I just don't like
when people talk without a complete
conversation
it's free
Instagram is free
for you
so they monetize by advertisers coming
to you that's like television
you know who else monetizes your data
television
you know who else monetize your data
newspapers you're reading the Wall
Street Journal you turn the page you
don't want to see that full page ad of
some financial service but they know
that if you're reading the Wall Street
Journal you might want Financial
Services
I don't know like people are
very interesting to me
because they're making money they're
making money
or they're getting entertainment
yeah no Tick Tock does not charge you
for all that entertainment every kid on
earth
gets unlimited entertainment on tick
tock for free meanwhile they have to pay
20 bucks a month or whatever Netflix how
much is Netflix now
right yeah right I don't like I don't
get it Like It's Entertainment for free
it's building audience for free like how
do you think this works I can't wait for
decentralization when it's based on
Merit and not the algo and the audience
is there we'll see how much people
reminisce about this time and what they
complained about I think one of the
things immigrants have a massive
advantage of
is they know the alternative yeah my
incredibly awesome Epic
friends who were born in this country
even if they travel a lot you don't
taste it the same way
you know I came from communist Russia my
even though I came when I was young the
first 15 years of my household even
though it was in America was just
unlimited conversations and stories of
just treacherous yeah sadness right you
know people dying in their 40s and 50s
see normal alcoholism because vodka
consumption in Russia suppression you
know anti-Semitism you know uh
persecution jail time fear just a sheer
level of you know I don't think I don't
think a lot of Americans realize that so
many people around the world live in
fear right you know
um and judgment and you know and I think
some of our social unrest
in the U.S in the last decade has given
people a taste of it but the Deltas for
all my for all the friends who are
listening right now who are Americans
it's you know people around the world if
you have the context like it's Amateur
hour are unrest you know compared to
around the world so
um that I I think because of that my
friend everything else flows the the the
inherent work ethic that comes along
with understanding the opportunity the
humility yeah you know people who are
electric engineers in one country come
here and wash dishes and clean toilets
and we'll do it in a second right
because they're like well in four years
I can right and so I think it's that
macro perspective of actual opportunity
actual opportunity right is a huge
driver and so I see the I see it in the
drive I see it in the humility and I see
it in the gratitude
and the complete lack of ego it's that
humility that I look for a lot the
number one thing I know that will work
for this audience is having a foundation
of two core things always following the
underpriced attention not the mature
attention and oh when I tell you
everybody focuses on the mature
attention because it's easy it's what
you're stuck in Instagram
that along with what are we gonna do
about a sustained content model
I think it's an interview show I will
always say this to this industry in an
industry that does their business
locally
standing up an interview show that
interviews people locally and then
chopping that up will work if you
interview the principal of the high
school
and do the right titling on a YouTube
short do you know how many people decide
where they want to buy a home based on
the education framework enough a lot
enough that if they watch the interview
of the principal that they're trying to
decide if they're going to go into this
town is being interviewed by you and you
happen to be selling homes that's called
business
interview shows are easy
because you have to do a little prep and
if you're like me you do no prep and you
just ask generic questions and you roll
with it
hey principal how's it going
I really need to figure out some
sentence in this room that unlocks you
to realize 10 12 pieces of content a day
is the only answer to the thing you're
thinking about
since we're at attention and content and
information is the only game
and other things have gotten mature when
I was doing SEO and sem in 1999 that was
underpriced attention
I'm how many people here have been doing
sem for their business for over 15 years
raise your hand anybody
right just a couple some of you remember
like remember how good of a deal that
was the stuff that used to pay 48 cents
for is now 73 dollars
apply and demand
I need you to understand supply and
demand of attention and I need you to
understand that it's going to be content
for a long time we are within the half
decade of people watching tick tock on
television 24 hours a day
social networks have won the next decade
brand and business is built in Social
you can do other things you've got
tactics that work I'm sure Direct Mail
outdoor networking you know what to do
it's tried and true
to get value out of me being here today
I need this to be the moment you finally
said [__] it I'm gonna go try it again
or forget I'm gonna try for the first
time or forget I'm gonna go 4X harder
because
it's really this wild moment in time
where all the attention is reshifting
and the macro industry is going to
decrease which means the winners in this
space are going to win and the winners
in my opinion are going to be the
content producers and you've got to find
your way I think that for me a high
performing team starts with retention
I basically the only more than
even how much money we have in the bank
I care more about how long are people
staying at the company on average
so for me a high performing team is
first based on retention
which is just black and white math on
the gray side the non-measurable
I use my intuition
on how happy are the people some people
stay in jobs because of money that is uh
often a gateway to unhappiness and so
it's not just retention it's it's
overall Common Sense slash intuition
slash emotional intelligence to get a
sense of how happy are they while
they're here
and then finally
um
I I judge performance or or know how
it's a high performing team based on the
results you know for all the warm and
fuzzies I'm sure you sense this in the
book that I wrote for all the warms and
fuzzies and la la and all this if you're
you know in that book are words like
tenacity and ambition and uh and I I
think work ethic matters and and I think
results matter I I think that so much of
the world's unhappiness and anxiety is
based on the fact that we eliminated or
demonized competition at the Youth Level
the idea that eighth place trophies are
a good idea is a huge mistake in my one
person's opinion and so the other way I
recognize if there's a high performing
team is if they're winning and in
business that means they're hitting
their financial goals both top line
revenue and profit for me not only do I
measure success financially Top Line and
below line revenue in a year I try to
look at it in a three five seven year
window thus giving and this is important
to hear thus giving a team the ability
to over focus on happiness and retention
in a given year that may actually hurt
them on their Top Line and bottom line
revenue but if I look at the body of
work
I'm always building businesses in
perpetuity you know we talk all about
building brand which is a marathon right
let's build a brand yet you know this
everybody here knows this the business
operators from the CFO down
uh care very much about sales
and we do many things to hurt our brand
in the face of hitting numbers and sales
because we are in corporate environments
held accountable to stock prices what's
great about running private businesses
is
I'm I went three I mean I've only been
running Boehner for 14 years there was
three years where we barely made a
profit
it was it was I was transitioning we
were growing up I wanted to try some
things I made a lot of mistakes we had
some casting issues uh we had some
product Market fit issues but
you know had I been a publicly traded
CEO I might have not been able to make
it to that fourth year in the window
that I'm referring to which ended up
being our highest profit year ever I
think the thing that most one of the
biggest reasons I understood that social
was going to work was
people didn't understand that humans
basic need is to communicate
basic human need is to communicate and
social allowed people to communicate
through pictures and words at scale
right and when I was an early investor
in Twitter everyone's like this is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard in my
life like in all of 2006 789 that was my
only conversation everyone was like who
cares if you have if you're walking the
dog who cares if you're eating pizza who
cares if you're going to Spain and my
answer was always consistent I said
everyone and it really really made
everyone struggle which is by the way at
that point no different than what
happened to me in 1997 when I said I'm
going to sell wine on the internet and
everybody in my world was like why would
anybody buy wine on the internet you can
go to the store who's going to buy wine
on the internet and I said everyone
and and that's because
what people struggle with is they make
decisions based on themselves
their opinions their self-interest where
they are in their career instead of
having the humility to look at scale to
human behavior history always tells you
the future I had an e-commerce site in
97. do you know how many people did not
want to put their credit card into a
computer
everybody here who has not wanted to
take the three hours of work to build a
custod a non-custodial wallet doesn't
realize they just became their parents
from 25 years ago
everything you made fun of your parents
for you've become and I think that's
cool because that's what P that's what
humans do but it's very true right for
us looking around this room it seemed
very simple in 99 and 2000 to put a
credit card in it didn't seem like high
friction to our 40 and 50 year old
parents it was massive they were
completely scared of getting their
credit cards scammed and things of that
nature that's just what happens you
became your folks the fact that it says
even the question gets exciting for me
because she said how fast can you build
a successful company
even that is why I think most people are
not winning
I've never thought of anything besides
how slow can I build something
but speed matters now I like I mean I I
think speed is the poison yeah okay
speed matters I also think it's why
nobody's winning
speed is the devil
but so sitting and analyzing and never
doing no right so there's an office
that's right there's a counter do you
know why everyone's sitting and
analyzing so much because they're trying
to figure out how to do it fast
speeds the devil
the the it was really funny obviously I
you know back to jumping in that was a
really fun moment right because I'm
saying tick tock tick tock because I
think you're gonna go where do you start
and that's that's why that's why I
didn't stop and I appreciate that I like
how you did it the reason I went so ham
four years ago on Tick Tock was I knew
what the question is from everyone I was
like this could actually get people
going because we've gone through five
years of mature Facebook and Instagram
and it was like there was no fast Tick
Tock was the first thing that I saw that
was fast completely based on the Merit
of the creative
but the problem is a lot of the people
that got it fast didn't necessarily go
into it trying to get it fast some of it
was on a spoof on a lark
some heard me and talked about they
cared about and because they cared about
it and they were passionate about Star
Trek and they knew a lot about Spock and
Captain Kirk it hit for the people that
also did
so you know I think the interesting part
of your question the answer to your
question is I if I was exactly me would
be okay because I've never wanted fast
because I've always sensed and now I
feel very confident that I'm right at 46
years old that fast is what's everyone
up because you go into shortcut land and
that's just real talk it just is
uh so I couldn't recommend more people
trying to think about things like okay
and this is why with the youngsters for
the youngsters I'm like listen
when you're 20
. if I'm telling you 10 years when
you're 20 you were 10 years old 10 years
ago and I remember being 22 and my
cousin Bobby being 30 and I thought my
cousin Bobby was the oldest man on Earth
so I know how hard it is when I tell
them hey think of this as a 10-year game
they're like [__] you Gary that feels
like forever the problem is it's why so
many 20 year olds lose it's also back to
mental health and all that it's why
they're all so anxious they want fast to
show everyone else they want
they don't want fast for any other
reason but to flex
and that's really [__] them up fast
is the devil the cancer is doing it for
other people thinking you made it
so now you got fast cancer is how most
of these kids are playing it you had so
you use some of that towards towards
your view like you you say it all the
time where people thought you were a
loser because you were the entrepreneur
like growing up you use that as a chip
on your shoulder chip on shoulder is
very different yes I to your point yes
but the problem is when I was growing up
and using get his chip of the shoulder I
wanted the Merit of success to be it I
never thought anyone on Earth would know
who I was
either in the business Community I
literally thought in the liquor business
people would know me and that was my
life
so I didn't grow up with what these kids
want almost every kid subconsciously
wants Fame
sane
reason why most actors and actresses
especially child ones went to rehab it's
hard back to what we're talking about
right I wanted chip on shoulders to like
be successful for the game
a lot which is why I never bought to
this day it's why I don't buy
because I don't want the proxy I didn't
want the Mercedes or BMW or Rolex or
house in the in Short Hills with a pool
and a house in the Hamptons I didn't
know the Hamptons exist until I was 30
years old I grew up in Jersey my whole
life I knew nothing about the flex
now back to chip on shoulder to your
point is motivation it's the perception
of success that all these kids want I'm
a big fan of trying to get real feedback
from human beings that interact with
human beings you know so when I'm making
decisions on hiring I try to see if I
can find a person or two that's close to
that person that doesn't have a horse in
the race that's worked with them in the
past the real real
um
and then you just observe it when they
work for you you know the way I pick
managers are the ones who have
you know these emotional intelligence
skills but you know listen there's some
very aggressive emotional intelligence
skills that matter ambition matters
for example you know one of the traits I
talk about in the book is ambition
ambition matters like somebody that's
hungry is going to achieve more it's
just that you know ambition
overpassiveness is a factor in winning
but but so is accountability so you have
ambitious people who don't like
accountability they like to blame
everybody else they like fingers not
thumbs
um so some of these skills kind of uh
contrast with each other yeah I think so
like you know to me being content and
being in like my life
wild levels of
complacent I wouldn't call complacency I
call it content I'm incredibly grateful
but actually that's the one I use number
gratitude and ambition could seem as a
contradiction I'm so grateful for
everything I have and don't have any
expectations no entitlement to more
but have incredible Drive
four more right yep so I think yes I do
think you know uh kindness and empathy
confuse people I laugh when people are
confused by that right
um curiosity is actually a heavy and
humility two things I talk a lot about
being curious and being humble but at
the same token conviction so I'm
incredibly curious but I have wild
conviction
you know humility is my ultimate pillar
of why I think I'm here today and being
honored to interview with you and all
the good things that are happening to me
but I have crazy conviction once I
believe something because I've tested
and learned it I was curious so I I
think these things do battle against
each other
um you know patience and tenacity are
two of the ingredients I talk about all
the time yeah imagine being equally
patient and tenacious
patience for me is a macro tenacity is a
micro
right so yep you have to be tenacious in
the task at hand but patient in the
overall mission and I think people
struggle with the levels they they
struggle with the macro micro
gotcha so you may have one level of one
and then a lower level of the other and
it kind of works together that's right
and and one may be something about life
and another might be the project at hand
I think humility number one I think the
super ingredient the super emotional
Nuance that most Alpha
winning leaders Miss is the power of
humility
for example for me with all the tenacity
and conviction and accountability and
self-awareness all the traits that I
talk about in the book that I have
um conviction I mean one of the reasons
I think I'm able to lead teams is
conviction there's no confusion for my
1500 employees where I'm taking the
company and what I care about
however I think the only thing that
makes me palpable the thing that makes
the whole engine the gas the electricity
the Sun that makes it all work is
humility and I think the biggest thing
for a lot of people watching here is
a lack of humility creates a humongous
Detachment between you and your team
and so uh something that's just
absolutely not talked enough about
whether you employ two people and have a
small business of three
or you have 800 people in your
department is how significant humility
is because it humanizes you it also
makes people feel safe
when you're willing to admit you don't
know or you messed up it allows your
direct reports and their reports to do
the same creating a much more
emotionally inclusive environment you
know we talk about thank God the world
Now talks a lot more about inclusion
from a gender and race and religion and
things of that nature however
I would argue that the biggest issue in
the world today is the weaponization of
fear
politically
parenting I think parents using fear to
parent the way they choose to is
actually creating a lot of vulnerability
in children and is the reason for
anxiety at scale and I would argue that
in corporate in business
bosses that use fear
instead of humility which triggers
safety
is the missing trait of the majority I
actually think it's because almost
everybody produces content from a place
of selfish
hmm
I just think that's what it is I when I
look at the content I'm like this person
could be good
but the only thing they're putting out
is for them to sell their course so
what's the recipe
put out content as if you work on
television or work at a newspaper or
work out radio from the 50s 60s 70s and
80s and media was a public service
domain
I'm a throwback I'm Walter Cronkite way
more than I'm anything else
and what I mean by that was Walter and I
don't the context was Walter Cronkite
was a newsman that was in an era where
they were taught when he was growing up
in the 30s and 40s and 50s that the news
was a public
public entity that it was there to
service the public
from the day I sort of went and it
happened I got very lucky in hindsight
of how I grew up in the game
I wanted to be content to review wine I
thought when I started Wine Library TV
in my head before I did it that I was
going to do QVC
I was gonna do videos and I'm gonna sell
wine
I have no idea why my DNA did this the
second of the I can actually pinpoint it
in episode one as a matter of fact team
I want to actually make this piece of
content I'm gonna pinpoint on an overlay
the second my life changed which is
within the first five minutes I have to
look at the video to get the exact time
I go into episode one I got three
bottles of Verte I remember the wine
because we had a lot of it and it was
profound like there was a part of me
that was selling good stuff thank God
right so like the wine was very good and
underpriced compared to Opus One and
Dominus and Silver Oak so I was like I'm
gonna make a good first episode but it
was there because I wanted to sell it
and within five minutes I'm like oh [__]
I'm not gonna sell on this show
I'm gonna act as if I left my dad's
business
and I'm just reviewing wine because I
have to be valuable to them
and I practiced a thousand episodes of
that reviewing wine which is why the
show went crazy the show confused
everybody if you look at the early
comments like wait a minute doesn't he
sell this wine
because I'm on the show saying all right
here we go
oh my God this one is incredibly
disappointing the mid palette is hollow
how are they charging 65 for this this
is an 18 bottle wine and people are like
what is going on and my own family was
my best friend Brandon my dad my cousin
Bobby all my employees were like have
you lost your mind we have 25 cases of
this who the [__] gonna buy this I'm
like people that don't watch a show like
I don't know like like and it was like
very real and then obviously when I went
to business content
it was never there like when I got
serious about vaynermedia I stopped
making content
every move I've made is very clear it's
there for my legacy
for being historically correct for
reputation building
right
which of course as a brand trickles down
into business people know you people but
it's not there as a monetizable
individual event unless I throw a right
hook yep and I'm comfortable when we
launch empathy to say hey buy it but
it's so infrequent so the world's
currency
of humanity is predicated on using fear
as a weapon and that starts at home
the reason we're conducive to it to
politicians is because our parents
deployed it from the beginning
then dig into a dad so I'm here and
there brother this has got me going like
you can't imagine I
am the byproduct of a mother
who it's so emotional for me it's like
tough to even talk about publicly I I'm
literally writing a book called
perfectly parented
of course I mean I could sit here for
six hours and tell you what my parents
did wrong but they so did right on
accountability and
and loving and cheering for the right
things my my mother didn't she punished
me for bad grades but there was never a
day where I thought my self-worth was
tied into my schoolwork
my self-worth was tied into the things
she cheered about and made important
which was how I treated other human
beings
when I mean these are real stories of my
life when somebody would fall and trip
and be hurt while we were playing in the
80s nobody thought about any of these
feelings and ideas and I would stop
playing and I would run over and care
about the kid that's the story my mom
would talk about over dinner
right when when I would stand up for the
kid that was getting picked on that's
what my mom not my parents overvalue
grades which teaches kids to believe in
systems that grade you subjectively
every hundred days
parents overvalue other parents opinion
of their kids which teaches kids to
Value other people's opinions
parents use fear to stop kids from doing
things that they're scared of
I'm scared list of dogs and water this
is real I Gary at 46 deep down I'm not
super comfortable around dogs and I fear
the water why because my mom did
and it's one of the few things I fear
around because it's one of the few
things that my mom and still fear around
if you fear getting a b you will work
for a company your whole life
we need to you know what this is not
Facebook I love when everyone's like
zucks sucks my [__]
people want to blame the algorithm
social media politicians governments we
have no level of accountability
parents on technology all day long and
then the second that they're having a
good time drinking wine they give the
iPad to the kid because they don't want
to be bothered
parents hypocrisy at scale
parents being way too involved in her
kids thus over protecting them thus
telling children that they don't trust
them to be able to handle their own has
led to
the moment we are in and until we accept
that truth until the older Millennials
gen xers or Boomers that [__] on gen Z
when they're the ones who parented them
until they become accountable for their
shortcomings and until we teach gen zirs
don't do what we did
play it different we'll just have a
Perpetual machine of insecurity how did
you develop
ment that's my question
I hung out with 80 year olds when I was
a kid
I gravitated towards grandparents and
great grandparents
um from a very young age my best friend
when we first came to America because we
were poor and everybody was working was
my great grandfather
um he passed unfortunately a year into
being in America but I have always
gravitated towards them and what you
learn when you spend time with 80 year
olds if I could tell anybody anything
here spend time with an 80 year old that
is not your grandparent just have a
combo a dinner uh strike up a
conversation to this day the only people
I strike up conversations with at
airports are people that I think look
like Yoda like are they 90 I want to
talk to them because they've lived it
they give you context and I'm practical
like you're 36 KP right like think about
this think about
think about
um 15 years ago when you were 21 you
probably remember your 21st birthday
right
it feels like yesterday and it feels
like seven trillion years ago right
right so if you think about those 15
years you could think about how much
you've accomplished how much opportunity
you had whether you accomplished it or
not how many reps how many at bats how
much time that actually is now what I do
is when I'm 36 and I do that 15 thing
then I go in 15 years I'll be 51. when
you hang out with older people you
realize 51's a child
I have unlimited 50 60 and 70 year old
friends
who act no different than my 30 year old
friends and so a lot of you see me
publicly going deep into youth culture I
love the kids I love the Gen zers the
young Millennials
um but I spend a lot of my not public
time with 60 70 80 year olds and it's
context and that context allows me to
understand what would you say to be the
turning point in your life that kind of
shifted to who you are today and what
could we take like from that like if
there's any advice that you can give to
us from something that's happened to you
in your life that made you to who you
are today
I don't think there's something super
clear brother I think what the real
answer to this question is something
happened to me between 9 and 14 that
isn't very clear to me still that
flipped me to a level of self-awareness
and confidence that guided me my whole
life
but like one thing that is very Bonkers
to me is how completely
non-penetratable I was to peer pressure
in high school
I still don't fully even understand it
to be honest
like when I recall the things I didn't
do in the face of why it would seemingly
be so easy and so obvious that you
should do that if you're a kid
good parenting good DNA circumstances
I do think there are some big advantages
of growing up in the dirt
you know
um but what I would tell you to give you
an answer that maybe brings value is how
quickly can you fall fully in love with
yourself
like that you're so in love with
yourself that you don't need validation
from anybody else
while you balance that love with of
yourself with extraordinary levels of
humility to offset the vulnerability of
loving yourself the mainstream media and
social media are doing a phenomenal job
of talking about negativity and what's
wrong just certainly notes fear cells
most of the parents in this room use
fear to control what they want their
kids to do it's how it's How Humans are
wired
the problem for me is I got lucky in the
DNA game and I have the greatest mom in
the world and a lot of great
circumstances that made me the reverse I
look at everything I just talked about
like if I'm sitting in this crowd
listening to this I'm pumped I want to
run through a wall and like take
everyone's money
[Music]
if you tweak your perspective on how the
world's operating
and instead of buying into the
propaganda for control of your mind you
look at the optimism that these tools
can create for you
if all of a sudden you look at your
employees like your teammates
literally I'm so affected by this if you
look at your employees I have 2 000
employees at vaynermedia alone
I genuinely think I've worked for them I
swear on my children's health I work for
them
of course you do if you're a great
leader and you want to build something
meaningful you work for them I was
raised by a dad who taught me the
reverse that's why I know the difference
and I used to be mad at my dad but then
I
kind of like a little bit older and
realize my dad grew up in the Soviet
Union where the country controlled
everything and the employees stole
everything the whole country ran on the
black market literally this is the first
oh I'm so I'm so mentioned earlier so
it's my birthday and I'm going to the
liquor store and I'm super sad no it's
not my birthday today I'm going back to
the story
a couple weeks ago so if you want to
clap it up I'll take it
so it's my 14th birthday I'm driving to
the liquor store
as you may be able to tell by the way
I'm talking I talk all the time
my dad does not talk we're completely
the opposite
we live 45 minutes from the liquor store
because my dad wanted to have land
because he likes cows and pigs so we're
45 minutes from the liquor store driving
on Route 78 in New Jersey to the liquor
store
my dad says no words
I'm talking a mile a minute like I'm
coming in dad and like wait till you see
what I got I'm gonna sell every bottle
of wine but like I'm like hyped even you
know like I was I didn't realize I was
gonna get paid two bucks an hour at this
point foreign
t one word he turns to me and he goes
keep an eye on the employees they like
to steal
that's what my dad taught me I grew up
in that environment I grew up in an
environment where I watched an owner be
in conflict with his employees
and then I've run businesses for 25
years where I've done the reverse an
investor in over 500 companies and
watched closely on tons of boards I'm
watching this is my passion
yeah
if you cannot deploy empathy and
compassion for your employees I once
said something my dad brought up this
weekend actually I said Dad if everybody
who worked for you was you they wouldn't
work for you
I tell a lot of my friends who struggle
with their employees I'm like I had a
buddy who's like I just want them to
work as hard as me I'm like then give
them equity in the business equal to you
thank you
we have to reframe this conversation you
have to make it enjoyable and
interesting not because you're soft
but because you want to make money we
are at a point in our lives where we all
be able to bear face them where what you
talk about a lot in regards to having
the most opportunity to take on risks
and try new things but sometimes you do
the calculations in your head and even
though the risk of failure is so low for
us right now there is still fear of
taking that step a voice telling you not
to what are different ways that we can
conquer that fear also why you curse so
much
I'll answer I'll answer the I'll answer
the easier one
I think somewhere along the line I
realized
if I just stay being myself a lot of
good things will happen in a world where
nobody stays themselves
and
I'm a Jersey Boy from the streets of
Edison New Jersey right like it is this
is how I talk it feels this is how it is
in my head no different than when you
wrote that down to ask the question like
that's what was in your head when I
curse it's in my head and what's
interesting is
it used to mainly only come out more in
like public speeches and things of that
nature and then you know like it just I
just never think brother right I'm never
thinking
right and what I mean by that is I'm
just being natural at all times and so
I don't even know when I'm cursing
genuinely really I really don't it
doesn't even register there's never been
a moment where like I love when people
like don't like it and they're like he's
forcing it I just laugh so much because
I'm like if these people knew how like
there if anything there are times where
I think about not trying to do it but
still can't control it because I'm just
in my flow
as far as your first question
it actually ties to the second question
when I started public speaking and
losing out on speaking gigs left and
right because I cursed
I
knew that I was going to double down on
what got me there which was I'm not
going to overvalue other people's
opinions I'm going to value my opinion
about myself
the little voice in your head
is called the insecurity devil
the insecurity devil on your shoulder is
your word is saying to you don't do this
because when you fail
the girl you like your brother your mom
your teacher like someone's gonna think
you suck and you believe them
and that's the problem
If people really got into a place of
just doing things that they want to do
and not worrying about what people
thought about it everybody would take
risks in their 20s
You by Nature being in this program
already taking risks that are different
than your contemporaries so you're
already halfway home
but this is still School
even though it's different
and the real world of jobs and companies
and starting your stuff that's the real
jungle
this is just cool right now what you're
doing
but the real jungle is scary because
there is no system it's not subjective
you know teacher Adam can't just say
you're good the world tells you the
truth
and people are scared of the world it's
why we have professional students
and so you know I think um
the reason people are scared of the
world is they actually think getting
fired or having their startup fail or
them not being able to be an influencer
because nobody gave is a bad thing when
I think it's a great thing
this all comes down to confidence and
insecurity
the reason you won't do something is you
are too insecure to do it the world was
changed by writers by Poets by musicians
by public speakers everyone here can
have the world they want the problem is
most people that are trying to do good
or optimism are quieter than people that
are trying to do negativity and bad
negativity and darkness and bad is loud
they're on the offense
positivity and happiness is content
thus not pushing themselves to be loud
one of the biggest things that I'm
trying to do is be loud in the face of
negativity right I see Vicki one of my
favorites Vicki J just like that like
like in the face of anything and
everything I always want to go positive
and do good and I'm empathetic to
people's feelings but I'm always going
to push positive things because it is
positive life is complicated there's a
lot of variables there's a lot of
nuances but positivity in this room
needs to be louder and so if he wants
that the reason he's not finding it is
he's not putting it into the universe
enough more creative more written word
more audio more video more jumping into
me saying yes to this I had these 30
minutes
as if like I would have rather have
somebody take a razor and slash my face
than allocate the 30 minutes to this
given how much work I have to do before
January 1st and yet I said yes to this
because intuitively I felt that I could
leave a positive impact in these 30
minutes to somebody within the 2000
people that are sitting here right now
and I was like and so it's painful and
like after I hang up I'm like I really
probably needed that 30 minutes but then
in nine months 16 months four years
somebody here is going to email me and
say I was listening to Twitter spaces
you said something about accountability
or kindness and it changed my life and
then all of a sudden it's all pro the
opportunity
for you to accomplish whatever the [__]
you're up to right now is never been
greater than it is right now we're thank
you
we're at full scale of web 2.
from Tick Tock to Facebook meta from
Tick Tock to meta
that's gonna be hard
um from Tick Tock to meta to YouTube to
podcast
you are now pretty much capable of
reaching almost any person on Earth if
you're good enough
my favorite other non-accountable thing
my Instagram's down because meta wants
me to just run ads and they're from with
the algorithm these
my favorite part of that is not true
Rick
here's what's actually happening
from Facebook to tick tock to Twitter to
YouTube they're just a blank supply and
demand machine
they all start out the same way
how many people here by show of hands
have been following me long enough that
when I get crazy and got crazy on Tick
Tock three years ago you listened and it
worked out for you raise your hands
let's clap it up for them that's awesome
so for the people that just raised their
hands for the people that just raised
their hands was that the first platform
that you built a big Community raise
your hand perfect so for those hands
what they realized when they went
through it was Oh What Gary's been
saying consistently is right you can
start at zero when a platform has a ton
of people consuming but not a ton of
people making content and the ads
haven't started yet it's just supply and
demand there's people consuming there's
people making the third variable that
always happens is eventually that
platform adds an advertising product and
over time more money goes into it but
there's still just one feed
it's just supply and demand it's real
estate it's the algorithm
the algorithm isn't trying to trick you
into spending ads you're just not better
than everybody else
you're not funnier
you're not better looking
you're not smarter
the algorithm is truth
your subjective feelings are false
this is a good thing this isn't bad this
is awesome when you realize that's true
you realize oh crap there are people
still exploding out of nowhere on
YouTube even though it's at scale when
you realize that you're like oh crap
there are people crushing on Instagram
right now even though the majority of us
me included organic reaches down
they're innovating they're adjusting
they go from a picture looking good with
lighting to making a reels because that
that's how the algorithm is working
the amount of humility that I find in
the business world is staggeringly low
the amount of humility that I see in the
business world is staggeringly low
why do I keep finding things like nfts
and Tick Tock and YouTube and Facebook
and Twitter and email and why is my
career my career
it's based on two things curiosity and
humility do you think I had a lot of
time in December and January this last
year to spend on reading about something
called nfts you think I had those 50 60
70 hours a week extra to keep digging in
in January I did not
what I had was curiosity and humility
curiosity because my Spidey senses said
there's something happening and by
listening and reading all your DMs and
comments all that time I put in that's
how I stumble on
but way more importantly than that
humility
I have friends when I ping them in
January
and said you need to Google this you
need to watch some of these YouTube
videos you need to read about this nft
they replied with my times too valuable
yeah you know where this next Line's
going
I am fascinated
fascinated by the lack of humility to
create innovation in the entrepreneur
and business world
people value their time and my favorite
part is this has now become very clear
to me the people that tend to Value
their time the most in my world when I
really analyze it are the peoples whose
time is the least valuable
self-awareness so this is the one that
I'm passionate about like for me so much
has worked for me because I understand
myself in space strengths weaknesses
yeah and also when you deploy empathy
with self-awareness by the way being
garyvee is all based on this like I'm
aware why somebody'd be like this dude
I'm empathetic to that I get all of it
it makes it palpable here's actually
talk about something that's powerful my
greatest fear was to create fear in my
companies I hate fear you don't want a
culture of fear in the business and
that's what I think everybody does yeah
and I didn't want to rule my fear
because I know it's a paranoid survive
and my dad ruled by fear so I became
very visceral to it
um
when I had to wake up four or five years
ago
and finally the subconscious became the
conscious and I realized that my lack of
candor
actually was creating a ton of fear at
vaynermedia because people didn't know
where they stood and you would have you
were telling people what they wanted to
hear you're you're
avoiding things that's right no I think
I was massaging I was trying to coach it
through in a different way I would I
didn't care about money so it creates
politics right because people were like
we're not getting the truth we got to do
this correct correct and more
importantly pandering to me because I'm
the ruler right and so when I really had
that that was a really dark moment for
me in my career because when you realize
the thing you most didn't want to do was
happening
and so then I had to Market to myself
I was like Candor doesn't work for me
and literally chipped away at it and
when the word kind went in front of it
it's been wild and by the way the last
18 24 months where my game has gone from
a 10 out of 100 to call it maybe I'm a
60 out of 100 right now
that 50.
has been Monumental in my business
success interesting and so that
motivated me to say
I can't believe how much of an impact
this is having because I had a lot of
things going for me but man just this
one what happens if I actually get
people to truly just deploy
accountability because everybody that is
listening right now has worked with
somebody who just blames people for
everything it just is with the way it is
and like if you make that change
everybody around you will adjust very
quickly right right
um patience I've come to learn was so
easy for me and is like impossible for
everybody mainly this is how I got down
the path mainly because I didn't realize
how many people valued other people's
opinions so of course you want to be
successful at 25 you want to show your
mom you want to show your friends you
want to show the world of course you're
lacking patience you want a BMW you want
to Rolex you want a blue check mark you
want a million followers you want to be
an entrepreneur and all this bad
behavior happened in the last decade
because of it a lot of people have
reached out to me in the last five years
on this
for people that follow me a lot of
people know I'm obsessed with context
obsessed with context it's why I'm a
very good marketer making videos on Tick
Tock is different than making videos on
LinkedIn
the way I talk to a 22 year old in
Germany is different than the way I'm
going to talk to a 45 year old in
Afghanistan
context is everything to me I'm
religious about context which is why I
think I'm one of the most successful
content producers in the world that's
why I think vaynermedia is one of the
most successful content producers in
advertising
when people like Gary I've noticed a big
change in you I remind them that my
message
is pretty consistent it's just
contextual if you read crush it my first
book will put me on the map I talk about
making forty eight thousand dollars a
year and loving life that if you were
ecstatic with your life and you're
making forty eight thousand dollars a
year you can stop reading this book
because this book is for people that are
unhappy and are looking for ways to get
out of the job that's making them
unhappy this YouTube and Twitter thing
and Facebook thing is going to be big
unlike our grandparents you can do this
after hours while you're at home with
your kids this is a big opportunity
most people saw the young ra ra ra ra
I wrote that book during an economic
crisis
for example if we go into a real deep
Global recession
my content is going to change
dramatically
because what's going to be needed in
that moment is to remind everybody that
hard work is part of the equation I
don't understand how people don't
realize that kindness is the single
strongest Foundation to building a huge
business
and let's let's have this talk I really
want to have this talk
I'm not on some ideology [__] up here
I'm not on some Zen Fufu Buddha up here
I'm on some I'm a better businessman
than all of you combined okay that's
where I'm at so let there be no
confusion when I talk over the next five
minutes I'm not on some like let's Zen
it out let's all be nice and Kumbaya I'm
on some off destroy every one of you
hard
okay
this is I have to say this because you
have to hear me
I believe that kindness is an alpha
Killer Business trait not some nice
additive to the way the world is today
here's why
it's sustainable
when you're building some how many
people here are building something for
themselves raise your hands
higher higher
thank you
there's a lot of people doing that in
this room
you have to understand why kindness
matters kindness matters cause you
yourself will feel better and you're the
engine
you have to understand why kindness
matters if you're kind to your employees
they stay longer continuity matters when
you're building something meaningful
you have to understand why kindness
matters if you don't over your vendors
by not paying them or doing the right if
you do the right thing they keep doing
business with you
you gotta understand why kindness
matters why the [__] did I buy this
sneaker
why
it does look good but why
this
this little swoosh is worth one trillion
dollars
that's called brand
when you're kind
and you do it for 15 years you build a
reputation
that reputation my friends is called
brand
we all of us have been taught way too
long for the last hundred years about
business that it's a dirty game
that it's a sharp elbows game
that if you're nice you'll get walked
all over game
it's not true
and I think it's time we start talking
about it
are you
seriously it's not true
it's not true it's not true and it's
time that we talk about it the people
that are the kindness most honorable
when you're so good that you have no
negative intent for anybody else if you
don't do wrong things you move fast how
do you prioritize your time how do you
make decisions on within you just gave
us a little bit of a sense of older
versus younger uh but how do you just
with a thousand priorities in a day say
this is what I'm going to focus on now
today next I have three full-time admins
and Two Chiefs of Staff
we have a one-hour meeting every
Thursday to look at the week ahead
we analyze every minute on the minute
the meeting I had right before here was
a 15-minute meeting the meeting before
that was a 15-minute meeting
um I get a lot done because I believe in
15s I think everybody in here has one
hour meetings that are actually seven
minute meetings you multiply that times
183 meetings a year you can imagine what
ends up happening with efficiency I go
with my intuition in my gut I've got a
ton of things going on I have eight
different companies inside of vaynerx
the holding company and I'm the active
Co vaynermedia so I'm a chairman of
seven other companies within that
holding Co I have V friends which is
taking up an enormous amount of time I
have my family my personal life I have
my non-profits I have garyvee the brand
I have tons of Investments I have a fund
I have a lot going on but the real
answer and this is gonna be a bomb the
real answer is I don't judge myself when
the last week wasn't as efficient as it
could have been
the number one reason that people
struggle with time management is because
they beat themselves up for not having a
productive week day or year
and they don't realize that it's just
subjective and they're grading their own
homework and they're themselves up
so people talk a little bit about that
it's this it's
industry I'll make a really interesting
copy and brought it up and I've watched
this industry from afar for a long time
I think the reason the industry is doing
better macro is we become less
transactional people are protecting
their brand they don't need the brand in
every category to maximize the p l they
realize that they make some sort of
silly thing for short-term money it
might hurt their overall thing that's
how I've always thought I've been very
patient I never do anything that can
tarnish me I I really work on that I
think it's important I don't I just
don't know how any level of money is
worth you not putting your head on a
pillow at night it doesn't make sense to
me it's not how I see the world
um and so I focus on that I also think
the world is abundant I also am
incredibly patient you know I spent the
first 12 years of my career building my
dad's business for him I started my
company at 34 years old in another
company's
conference room because we had no money
I was 34 before I ever made a hundred
thousand dollars a year like
[Music]
I'm so anxious everyone wants it so fast
everybody wants to keep up with the
Joneses they want to make it now so they
can show or enjoy like to me enjoying
the process of your career not the money
you make from your career so you can
then enjoy it
and that's the game I play what are the
soft skills that make for a great
founder what role has kindness played in
building your success Gary kindness is
the foundation to retention retention is
how you build a real company number one
uh I think accountability is number one
I am baffled by leaders ability to blame
everybody but themselves if you're a
leader by Nature everything is your
fault
and so I took accountability and
everything that's happened in my
personal life and my professional life
and everything in between and so it
doesn't mean I mean I have plenty of
feelings in my personal and professional
life of like what the other parties had
to do uh and and but I don't spend time
on blame or dwelling the number one
characteristic of a a winner leader is
uh is accountability I think compassion
and empathy is the next the reason I
hold no grudges is I understand why
and so I think compassion
and the empathy mixed in with
accountability I think competitiveness
is a major factor I think the world has
demonized competition in the last 30
years in a very unfortunate way I think
eighth place trophies actually lead to a
lot of anxiety and depression with
children now 20 and 30 year olds not the
reverse Merit matters and so I think
competitiveness matters tenacity
ambition uh these are kind of the hard
soft skills and then on the soft soft
skills it's definitely kindness empathy
caring being sweet approachable like I
just don't understand how people don't
know that likability is a direct
correlation to something that's healthy
I give you a sense of how I grew up
I'm the least interested person
[Music]
of entitlement leads to anxiety and
depression I think entitlement is poison
however there are way too many business
owners in this room that deploy very
quick entitlement on their employees
based on age discrimination without
factoring in the opportunities that 24
year olds have to make money today just
because you worked for nine dollars an
hour at Safeway
doesn't mean they should when they know
how to make thirty thousand dollars a
year making tick tocks
I understand what you would like the
kids to do for your business
but that is not the reality of the world
until business owners wake up to the
options
that the internet has created and start
really thinking about how they manage
not to be soft and fluffy I hate a gen
zir as much as everybody else
but I know I also hate Boomers because I
know 40 000 Boomers that are laziest
this is not an generational thing
this is a human by human thing the
difference is when I was growing up in
the game if I had the options
to make money that the internet now
provides for me when I was 11 years old
graduating college I wouldn't have
graduated Middle School
we can't fight reality
because I watch it a little bit I can't
speak to anybody here individually other
than I saw some of the people hashtag
this event that I looked at their
accounts and paid attention how much
they're posting and you really aren't
posting
um
we can't fight reality
we can't fight the reality of where our
customers attention is I understand that
you've done direct mail and you're
comfortable with it and you don't know
how to run Facebook ads it doesn't
change the fact that Facebook ads
perfectly destroyed Direct Mail
perfectly every day of the week
I understand you're comfortable with it
but it doesn't mean it's the truth
I understand you worked hard and grinded
and you expect everybody to do that but
your whole I walk 10 miles and 13 inches
of snow doesn't mean anything
we have to reverse engineer the reality
of the market that doesn't mean be soft
we have businesses to run
as a matter of fact I'll go the other
way
the amount of people that have Labor in
their stores every day
and there's nothing going on should be
required I mean if I could control every
business here I would have every person
in our stores that has downtime
producing tick tocks and Instagram and
YouTube instead of standing there
waiting for somebody to come in
Bachelor for instance right this doesn't
have to be hard this has to be a reframe
of thinking when you hear 15 a day it
gets real scary when you know that you
have unlimited employees just hanging
around waiting for people to come into
the store
all of a sudden you get real excited
about we can do 40 a day if I get Carl
and Sally to do some [__]
and all of a sudden you're not pissed
that they're on the phone dming trying
to hook up tonight you're pumped that
they're on the phone making some content
to drive your business 2023 is not 2015.
it's not 2009. it's definitely not 2
000.
and looking around it's definitely not
1994.
we have to adapt
mentally when I was doing SEO and sem in
1999 that was underpriced attention
how many people here have been doing s
sem for their business for over 15 years
raise your hand anybody
right just a couple some of you remember
like remember how good of a deal that
was the stuff that used to pay 48 cents
for is now 73 dollars
supply and demand
I need you to understand supply and
demand of attention and I need you to
understand that it's going to be content
for a long time we are within the half
decade of people watching tick tock on
television 24 hours a day
social networks have won the next decade
brand and business is built in Social
you can do other things you've got
tactics that work I'm sure Direct Mail
outdoor networking you know what to do
it's tried and true
to get value out of me being here today
I need this to be the moment you finally
said [__] it I'm gonna go try it again
or forget I'm gonna try for the first
time or forget I'm gonna go 4X harder
because
it's really this wild moment in time
where all the attention is reshifting
and the macro industry is going to
decrease which means the winners in this
space are going to win and the winners
in my opinion are going to be the
content producers and you've got to find
your way and it's tough because the
platforms I'm telling you are video
based
you know everybody loved Instagram
because it was easy
I'm gonna take a photo
it's gonna look real good after I filter
the [__] out of myself
and then I'm going to write a couple
sentences and it's gonna be super cool
that is not the current Marketplace I
know you want it to be because that's a
float easier than what you need to do
now but whether it's a podcast a local
show
one-offs you're gonna need to figure out
what your pillar content is
so that you then can cut up and produce
you're also more than welcome if you
love The Game and you've got the time to
produce for it but I know it's not going
to be sustainable for most of you which
is why I'm pushing this pillar and and I
put I put this out a long time ago and a
lot of people built businesses in many
different Industries off of it but I
think if you Google and maybe somebody
here can confirm it right now but if you
put you know
um Gary vaynerchuk content model 84
pieces
I put that a long time ago it's
obviously the macros right some of the
you know details obviously change but
it'll give you a sense of what I'm
talking about of like you know make a
macro thing post-produce again so many
people here raise their hand following
me it's all I do it's very obvious to
you you see what I do I re I bring up
stuff from nine years ago and then clip
me talking about something about night
like you just have to put yourself in a
position to actually do it but I'm
telling you and I'll leave with this and
we'll go into the chat
it's the answer to the quiz
you cannot leave Las Vegas and not
produce a lot of content if you want to
grow or sustain you can do whatever you
want
you're not my children I actually give
no
I would just prefer you win because it's
nice and I like getting the emails four
years later three years later like it's
nice I'd like you to win
this is the one thing you can control
the most
I know it's around self-esteem and
self-awareness of how to produce the
macro thing written word audio video
figure it out but figure it out the
first time we met you mentioned that we
are the future of the company and I'm in
that within this Residency program I've
been having that as a mindset going into
the next five years what is the best
mindset that and the learning path that
I can take to become the future of this
company
and I'm not saying come where you are
I'm just saying like to grow in this
company and to be to be a big part of it
uh it's a great question I think a
couple things one is self-awareness
you know
let me give you an example of what I
mean by that there are plenty of times
and I'm as happy as it gets
professionally and there are still
plenty of times that I say huh I wonder
how cool it would have been to have the
DNA that would have made me pause like
I'm envious of a lot of my senior
employees
I'm like you know
you know like yesterday like being sick
that was it was not only bad to have 103
fever it was even worse knowing that I
was missing things that were really
important and like I can't like rely on
anybody else to do that role
so I think first of all self-awareness
when you have ambition
you know even you asking that question
my fear is that you push yourself into
places on an ideology versus the reality
of who you actually are
so I think the best way people can be
the future of this company is
one they have a good sense of themselves
two they have a good sense of what they
want in life financially creatively
work-life balance three this is a big
one I want everybody to pay attention to
this one three
that they have the capacity to change
their mind five years from now so some
of you right now might be like I
actually do want Gary's job I want to be
the C Global CEO of vaynerx in 20 years
and I think that's rad
on the flip side you may fall deeply
deeply in love in seven years
and then start a family and be like that
you know I want to be like my mom or dad
or I want to be the reverse of my mom
and dad and I want to be at every
recital and every ball game and that's
not going to let you be the global CEO
of vaynerx that's just real talk
so I think that if you have a good sense
of who you are if you're comfortable
in who you are and if you're willing to
change your mind of what you want that's
a huge starting point do you know why
people are not nice because they do
they're grasping at straws they're
they've caught a tiger by the tail and
have a relationship with a nice person
or they have a nice boss they're scared
every single day for that person to
leave because that person is the energy
of balance because they themselves are
super hurt inside they're hurt
because they haven't put the poison into
the world
they've demonized therapy so they don't
do that if they've done that they
definitely don't tell normal people
they peacock and hide behind money
find status behind things
my friends the world is this close
the reason it feels so far away is
occasionally people come around and
realize how much fear works
how much demonizing others works it
makes people feel safe for a second
it is the least sustainable thing in the
world
world you know how I know this
I was an atrocious student
but there was one class I was always
good at history
I never understood why and then finally
in my 30s I realized oh because my
entrepreneurial Spirit knew that I would
need it to recognize pattern recognition
today many people
on me were laughing me because I believe
in nfts
in a decade
in a decade I'm gonna laugh at them you
know how I know this
history in 1996 I told anybody that
would listen to me that the internet was
a very good thing in 1999 when the stock
market crashed everybody said the
internet was a fad in 2005
in 2007 I was in Germany three times for
three different talks talking about
social media
how Twitter was phenomenal and I was on
a panel with debating somebody and they
said to the crowd how many people think
Twitter is stupid and everybody raised
their hand
everybody
and the person interviewed me said Gary
why is Twitter so important and I said
because people are gonna tweet that
they're walking their dog
everybody laughed
not at it at me
the reporter rightfully said that sounds
ludicrous who cares if somebody's
walking their dog by reply
everyone
I suck at almost everything
people are so confused how the world
Works everybody in this room pretty much
sucks at almost everything
except a couple things
I suck at almost everything but the one
thing that has been with me
since I was a child when I listened to
my late Grandma's stories about me from
zero to seven or my mother's it's very
clear that DNA is a remarkably powerful
thing
I suck at almost everything except one
I know you collectively as well as any
person that works on Earth I understand
people I do it comes to me it's natural
to me and I'm so grateful for it because
I have such deep wants for it to be good
I'm in such a good place and I want you
to be in a good place
I I definitely don't always win but I'm
always but I'm always playing to win
you know like I want to win like I want
my companies to be the biggest I want to
win it's my game like what are we doing
here it's a game I want to win I don't
think that's a bad thing I'm fiercely
competitive however
I do think that for me at least I don't
think my winning comes out of anybody
else's pocket so for me it's like I'm
gonna win but I want everybody else to
win too in the agency land when we pitch
a new piece of business if another
agency wins all right like we lost like
we didn't tell the client what they
wanted here they went somewhere else
it's not like I hate Johnny or Ricky you
know I I get pumped watching all these
projects do well I don't think the
friends not being the number one valued
project is bad like I think when all the
dust settles in 22 years you're gonna
forget about a lot of names that we've
got with today and I'm going to be
dominating but if I don't
I'm gonna be pumped for World of women
or board ape or you know whoever yeah
like I I don't I'm surprised that people
don't know how to balance
trying to be successful and enjoying
their process and loving their game and
being competitive with also being okay
for rooting for everyone else including
people that are direct competitors
I just think the world is abundant and I
I'm gonna get mine nobody's stopping me
from getting mine which is why I cheer
for everybody else to get theirs I
really do feel a tremendous sense of
responsibility I genuinely sit here this
morning looking at all of you and my
chemicals and my emotions are I work for
them what I just want to say is thank
you because I think we've all worked
extremely hard this year I genuinely
believe that part is something we'll
always do because I just know the makeup
of this team there's a lot of people
that roll that way here we've benefited
from this and I know a lot of you have
felt this and I've heard this from a lot
of you especially for the OG's here more
so than in a long time I think we had a
very clear Focus the way I look at
everybody here is the way I look at
leadership in general parenting being a
president we have no room in any shape
or form in any situation to not treat
each other or anybody that we interact
with with anything other than super Glee
joyful deep love optimism rainbows and
unicorns here's why because that's what
I do for you
this is very important to me we are at
our worst when the Delta between how I
treat you is different than how you
treat anybody you interact with
since I don't manage you with fear or
negativity why on Earth would we and by
the way this almost makes me want to cry
the amount of issues we have on this
issue here is quite low when I say this
please let everyone know that it's
almost non-existent
I want it to be zero do you have any
advice of like how to like start
conversations like how to like just get
better at Like Making Connections the
only way to get better at networking is
realizing why you're scared of people's
judgment it's it's something I deal with
like my hope it's not about a technique
it's why do you actually worry that if
Dustin you come up to him and want to
network him and he's like no why does
that make you feel bad you need to
figure that out exactly that's right let
me give you the secret yeah it doesn't
matter if you can remember that moment
and realize all of them are Dustin yeah
it's not like you really it's like don't
value someone's opinion about you more
than the value that you put on yourself
about you I know I got to I gotta do so
start practicing what happens next you
practice you like really practice yeah
you just go and actually Network and
just do it and like feel the pain and
the awkwardness until it's gone how do
you succeed in doing videos on things
you know or passionate if somebody else
is already in and succeeding at it
nobody else is winning is coming out of
yours
if that was true the game was over a
long time ago that's right why did
LeBron try to pass Kareem oh Kareem was
the all-time leading scorer yeah like
why is Kevin Hart doing that Eddie
Murphy did that already but why did
Eddie Murphy do that Richard Pryor
already did yeah what are we talking
about here this Con excuses like that
and notice the word I used excuses like
that are just people that are scared to
do the thing and fail on Merit they feel
better that somebody already took it
the world is abundant if you're good
enough
no matter how much is already taken you
can get yours too
I wasn't the first person to talk about
kindness I was the first person to talk
about work I wasn't the first person to
talk about technology that is a
ludicrous point of view and I come from
a place of compassion when I use that
statement that person needs to realize
that's a subconscious excuse to not do
yeah and it's better to blame that oh
they didn't get lucky somebody already
did it versus them having to put in the
work to do it if you could get one piece
of advice as far as a step in the right
direction for people that are ready to
stop working and get into
entrepreneurship where do you start you
start by first being self-aware a lot of
people actually aren't going to be good
at entrepreneurship they just might need
a job that they like more almost nobody
likes their job the stunning majority
are dislike or at best neutral about it
they're not on fire they're not waking
up on Monday like let's go and so to me
LinkedIn no different than you listening
to One Piece of content for me that
changed the course for you because you
figured out this where somebody right
now who's watching this if they realize
they can post things about their
opinions their observations and their
expertise about what they do for a
living if you're a five-year lawyer and
you say something I'm seeing in law
around IP law and you write four
sentences you make a video it depends on
how you communicate written word or
video one piece of content on LinkedIn
where you have no followers right now
can change the course of your life
because now you have inbound people
offering you jobs instead of you sitting
and dwelling
about hating your job and after six
months to a year there's a piece of
content that's going to come out that's
going to lead to the next job
opportunity that's what I think people
should do every second you spend
thinking about what somebody else has is
taking away from time that you could
create something for yourself
[Music]
you're losing you lose you're losing
because you're laying in your bed
looking at somebody's glamorous
photoshopped picture of them doing
something cool and you're envious and
you're jealous and you're impatient and
it's crippling your upside
yeah because that's where I want to be
and I know I'm not there yet you haven't
done
I know so go douche that actually gets
you there so that you earn it instead of
like you dwelling that you're not there
and hoping something's gonna happen I
don't know what's going through your
mind you've got to deploy patience and
you've got to love the process I'm
addicted to the process of the Battle
Scars the setbacks the lack of you know
Taylor I gave up my entire 20s all of
them imagine not doing anything fun or
going anywhere for the next eight years
including Saturday and Sunday that's
what I did from 22 to 30 every day I
spent 15 hours a day in a liquor store
thought about a liquor store built a
liquor store sold wine like spent every
day like this last weekend don't lie to
me Taylor what did you do this last
weekend what did you do Saturday and
Sunday tell me the truth don't [__]
me
yeah no Bulls um I'm helping my mom
right now on visual media and branding
for her company and so I had a marketing
meeting with one of the people doing
that love you and then I also how much
time did you have how much how much time
did you have for yourself on Saturday
and Sunday that was not working every
minute tell me the truth
a lot a lot I know so that's the punch
line right now imagine this when I tell
you this you spent more down time on not
your career this weekend than I did in
my entire 20s combined just tell me why
seven million dollars is uh is a bargain
for uh for an Advertiser this year I
mean it all comes down to attention
right like the reality is his attention
is the number one asset and not
potential attention and you have the
entire country actually focused on
watching Super Bowl ads which is unlike
any other television commercial that
runs in any shape or any form obviously
the commercial has to be good to make
the thing happen but the attention is
underpriced compared to the cost per
attention in every other environment
that we see in Digital television or
traditional advertising
cause I mean if a hundred million people
in the US watch it that's some of the
estimates this year if that's the case
that yeah it's always been the most
widely watched event of the year but
compared to the single audience of any
other program show any place you can
find people assembled it's that much
bigger on a relative basis does that
actually translate directly into return
on investment no it doesn't it's that
Americans actually want to watch the
commercials nobody wants to watch the
commercials on the Grammys nobody wants
to watch the commercials on the Oscars
nobody wants to watch the commercials in
the AFC and NFC Championship game or the
NBA finals this is the only time people
in America actually want to watch a
commercial thus rendering it the best
deal while all the other commercials on
television are grossly overpriced
here in truth have you ever thought
about creating your own reality TV show
um no but I do think the Vlog has a
little bit of that obviously you
probably know this I'm quite private
you know I share nothing about my family
or personal life
um so I don't like I the reason I first
of all I would have never I would never
let a network have that much control or
economic upside knowing the world that I
live in but even then I have too much
empathy for them because they would want
all the other stuff and that's just a
line I'm not willing to cross so no but
but I definitely think the Vlog and what
we do at dailyvee gets into the nuances
of it
um and I enjoyed the the ability to
control the narrative and uh and not do
hellacious things for Nielsen ratings
and you know I'm just not willing listen
I am never ever going to be part of a
machine that I don't control
because it doesn't sound interesting to
me and uh that's why I would never do
that I'd like to hear about team garyvee
like and a lot of people think okay to
do this because you say I went on Tick
Tock but part of the way you're doing
that is because people are multiplying
your content you're casting Vision can
you speak into maybe we team garyvee is
pretty Advanced now can we start a
little bit at the beginning as you think
about those that would say what am I
what about my first hires how do I even
do this I rape at real estate or
financial services but okay how do I
start you know every where do I get my
drock where do I get the whole thing
speak to early stages of building that
team to help you grow with video
you need to hire people that do things
that you don't want to do
where do you find them
the internet
[Music]
[Applause]
people
say things that drive me crazy because
they don't want to do it
as if you can't find it
are you telling me you're at this
conference and you can't find people
you don't know what Fiverr is you don't
know how to post on LinkedIn you don't
know how to search terms on Twitter like
people come up with excuses a lot of
people a lot of people don't grow
because they want money to buy things
um yeah a lot of people's businesses
don't grow because they want the
business to give them money so they can
get a Corvette
or a second this is back to you've got
to find the thing you like
because if you're building a brand or
your thing to buy the yacht
you're not going to build a very big
thing
I'm just building the thing to build the
it's more interesting for me to build
the thing I think about leadership from
this concept of gray not black or white
most leaders are going to be either
black or white it's not Empire of honey
it's honey Empire nothing works unless
there's Humanity the number one job of a
leader is to eliminate fear the reason
we call it the Honey Empire when we talk
about leadership is you get more out of
honey than vinegar you may get
short-term wins in vinegar but you will
not get sustained winds with vinegar
then there's the opposite side the me
that everything's bubble gum and
rainbows and you're putting it all on
you but you're quietly building
resentment you have to work on what I've
worked on for the last five years which
is the ability to deliver what we call
kind Candor but I realize that Candor
that corporations love to stand up was
really for a lot of people an excuse to
be mean an excuse to control someone
that they're managing so that they don't
Propel you know how much human
psychology goes into a manager that
consciously knows the person they're
managing is more talented than them
there's a subconscious repression going
on there because they don't want it to
happen
so Candor all of a sudden became
manipulation
so Candor I always really struggled with
somehow some way because I was working
on myself I sold myself on the concept
of this term called kind Candor and has
transformed our company because what was
happening for us was
you know I'm the CEO of the company I'm
the founder of the company so you're
listening to me for 10 minutes here I
think you're getting a sense of how we
roll the problem is we were on the
opposite side we created unlimited
entitlement if nobody's getting any
critical feedback and nobody's allowed
to say anything to anybody it went the
other way
we were two over here I genuinely
believe that every single thing at
vaynerx all 1900 people that every
single thing that isn't working is 100
my fault
I really believe that's leadership
here's why I could be mad at project
manager my hired the head of production
management the CEO did my hired the clo
like there you have to fall in love with
accountability if you have any interest
in leadership you have to fall in love
with it and most people don't want it
especially now
pop culture right now is in love with
pointing fingers everything's about
pointing fingers
most of us here looking around we've all
now are deep in our understanding of all
the things our parents [__] up on
is like
say right like we are
acknowledge of every thought we have
about Mom and Dad right now my question
is like when does that stop
cool all right great agreed
inconceivable that someone is sitting
here that doesn't have thoughts about
that my question is at what age do you
take control and fix it
for you
and that's how I think about leadership
I think there's such an opportunity if
we just get real about it and find that
middle
there's incredible
happiness that comes along with a
hundred percent accountability
because you feel like you're in control
all of it is stemming on the same thing
if you don't feel like you're in control
as a human being you were unhappy the
leadership of your own self
starts to become the practice that you
can deploy for others every single thing
I'm disappointed with my default in my
brain goes into how did I not put this
person in the position to succeed so
that is now leading to the thing I'm
frustrated about what didn't I do your
own pain and frustration you're
deploying on others
right so that's what you're bringing to
the meetings and the energy
we just have to find a way to get all
that poison out
you've got to get it out that's all it
ever is it's just beer what is your
message
to our billion public listeners and fans
that um if they can build a relationship
with time and realize they have a lot
more time
that they will have far less anxiety
and that using a sports analogy if
you're down by 13 going into the fourth
quarter
and you win by four you won by four
and a lot of people's fourth quarter in
a basketball reference and in life
reference is really ages 55 to 80. so
I'd like to hear from everybody that's
under 40. what are they so upset about
that they haven't accomplished yet you
have more than half your life to do it
everyone's talking about be authentic
the problem is when all these people are
consuming you they're consuming you know
uh everyone else on the planet and then
they put out content and the hardest
part is where does their Voice start
where does their voice
listening to you say I'm empathetic to
those like I'm listening right now I
think about it all the time I'm like am
I the seed of things
you know like for me it's easy and so I
actually
this is a very important question
I could most people are sponges you
ready for this yeah I consume nobody and
haven't I actually think the reason I've
been very original
is I don't consume anything
I consume everyone
but I don't consume any other
person that does what I do you consume
the listeners I consume the comments
I'm so first of all you know this
because you have a little bit of insight
I'm a very weird character most people
have no concept that I'm running a 350
million dollar a year Global agency
every day actually
like you and you know you just walked in
here I'm finishing off a meeting with a
Fortune 50 CMO like literally just
closing so let's go right like it's what
I do yep so that in itself isn't insane
then I have real love for my family and
want to live that personal life
and then I'm like me and I'm a maniac
I'm doing garyvee and I'm doing V
friends and I'm doing like garage
selling like and so I don't have time to
consume anything but the consumer
consuming somebody else that's
synthesizing the consumer
has no value for me so your advice says
everyone turn off everyone and just put
out the content about you based on them
listening to everybody so for example
when nobody on Earth knew who I was and
I was doing wine I read Twitter 20
million hours a day
to read every single person's point of
view online one of the things that are
needed to be successful in life there's
a lot of things that come to mind a lot
of what I think about is self-esteem and
genuinely being in a good place with
yourself because you won't put yourself
out there at the level you need to if
you're insecure
and so I think a lot about self-esteem
and self-love and a lot of other stuff
but the word that I want to talk about
is the word curiosity
I think everybody here
can probably sense
that this web 3.0 last year we we
defined web 3.0 as crypto and nfts
but I I challenge that concept and I say
let's take a step back and realize web
3.0 probably encompasses a lot more
things for me personally it encompasses
AR for me personally it even encompasses
something that's been around for a long
time like QR codes because I think it
says in functionality in pipes that
matters for everyone here it definitely
involves ZR and we know that and it
clearly involves AI which is going to be
such a big deal
we me included were very stuck in what
we're doing right now
meanwhile this is probably the biggest
era of change coming up since the
invention of the iPhone accelerated
social media in a profound way I have a
feeling that a lot of people here
you're not sure exactly every aspect
none of us are but I have a feeling
everybody can feel here that the next 20
years she's gonna look a little bit
different
that between Ai and AR and VR and
decentralized servers like it just feels
like it's not the status quo that the
last 15 years are
in that will be some of the biggest
opportunities that you will ever see in
your entire life in 1997 and 1998 every
internet company that went public was
worth a billion dollars with zero
Revenue all of those stocks collapsed
but it didn't mean that the internet was
not going to be one of the biggest
inventions of our time
that's just blockchain that's not even
mentioning what's going on in Ai and in
the last year
everybody here has been affected and
Blown Away
by Jasper or mid-journey or chat GPT all
of us have tasted real AI not fake AI
like we were for the last seven years
and it really caught everyone's
attention
these things are going to converge
together
at scale and so I asked all of you
please do not leave this conference
without asking yourself how curious are
you
you know how many of you here have
opinions about AI yet you've never spent
50 hours really using it
you know how many people here have
opinions about everything that's going
on in new technology yet it's because
your friend told you or you read two
articles you didn't have the Curiosity
to go all in you lead with no sometimes
you lead with yes but very few lead with
maybe
if you leave with anything from this
talk given how young this audience is if
you can fall in love with the concept of
maybe
when faced with somebody telling you
something you've never heard about
before or something new in your journey
which will be consistent for the rest of
our lives with technology if you meet
that new genre that new platform that
new technology with the concept of maybe
you will have a much greater chance to
get out of the world what you want and
so I argue at stale that one of the
biggest things to lean into within your
own body
going into the next decade is finding
out for yourself with yourself where do
you sit with curiosity are you a curious
person or are you not and how do you
develop more curiosity for me the way I
built more curiosity was I started
surrounding myself with people that were
more curious
and so I challenge you to really think
about this because it will really matter
if you were able to go back to yeah what
are you telling them one piece of advice
with his entrepreneurial and this is
gonna be a tough one because I was so
extreme in this direction so this may
not help you but it might in the direct
but it might help you in a macro it's
okay to take a Saturday off I was 110
work okay and I do believe that balance
is best at in hindsight a little few
vacation days a few Saturdays a few ball
games just like doing besides working
again being 20. some 20 year olds it's
like hey you need to start building your
discipline and work ethic other 20 year
olds it's like hey don't put too much
pressure on yourself yeah number one
number one it's all great to like take
advantage of your youth a lot of kids
that are overly soft and overly like not
starting to do things that are
inconvenient wake up at 30 and are
struggling too so like the best thing I
can tell a 20 year old who's a little
too chill if you actually believe even
for you you are find something to be
disciplined about that might be the gym
that might be school just one thing to
get you into big tolerance of
inconvenience too many people just want
everything to be easy and the ultimate
Comfort is not finding ways to be
comfortable the ultimate Comfort is to
know that you are comfortable in any
adversity what you see is the next Big
Industry that's gonna
be not maybe fully disrupted but web3 is
going to start to enter like you know
with music right now I'd say it's very
very early
um but do you think that'll be the next
one to continue growing or will it be
gaming or
I think really any consumable is in play
like fashion gaming sports entertainment
I think all of those are going to be you
know impacted
um
you know I think I think a lot of B2B
stuff the boring legal yeah law firms
you know like just like documentation
like where did things sit
um
yeah
I and I'm like I do think the
entertainment business like
why couldn't a streaming service come
along that's built on nft infrastructure
instead of like you know what I mean
like
like why couldn't that be the
subscription subscriptions contracts you
know I think a lot about so
that's what I see right now uh you know
you mentioned like in terms of fashion
so if we look at Fashion
where they're selling a physical product
you know I've been in the belief it's
very early but I've been a belief that
you know the physical products are a lot
if not all of them are going to have
like an Associated nft
they will and then the question becomes
is that physical product held up in an
exchange in a warehouse and you don't
take ownership of it like stockx
and you're just trading the nft that
represents it and then when I actually
want to get that eight million dollar
painting into my apartment I have to
burn the nft to get the actual physical
or is it just a nice
receipt
where you can separate the because once
you give it to the person if you give
them the physical and the nft well
they're detached because I can just sell
off the entity or I can just sell off
the physical and there's no technology I
can keep track yeah whereas if I sell
you a fifteen thousand dollar handbag
and I give you the nft and the handbag
sits in a mercile exchange like
environment then I can actually trade
the nft and then if you actually want
the bag you can burn the nft in
Redemption of yeah because what I'm
getting at is you know the
especially with luxury goods but the
second hand uh secondary Market with
Fakes and that sort of thing right I
really seen nfts as a way to help combat
that but it's so difficult now because
yeah once the technology one's a
physical product so it's correct and
once you take ownership of it you can't
you know it's not going to prove
Providence unless it's sitting but
that's important there's a lot of people
that buy something very valuable to have
they want to know it's real if they buy
it in nft form to burn to take physical
at accountability of it then you're good
that's huge yeah
that's huge yeah at least for that first
secondary sale for that first secondary
sell you got it or
Burns it
there could be 99
sitting in docks around the world for
tax Havens or how much how much wine
sitting in wine cellars do you know how
many sports cards are sitting in safety
deposit boxes
you know like a lot of people don't need
the the actual physical thing
it I don't I'm not my public stock is
not sitting in my hands right right the
knowledge of
um and then over time the nft becomes
the thing
owning the nft is owning the birken bag
at scale Burger bag I can only you know
rare pair of sneakers only so many
people can see me wearing them but once
this scales to like social media like
levels like people are gonna be like
what nfts does that person have I'd have
to make some compromises not mentally
allowing me to agree that I'm making
these compromises professionally in my
30s I feel like that's
that's what you have to have I would
actually argue some of my least
productive years of my career were in my
30s ironically 30 was what I triggered
in if I said right now as an athlete
what were your worst seasons I would say
28-29 for the only time my career I had
micro I'm even scared to say it out loud
micro complacency but Wine Library did
it so from 22 to 28 I didn't breathe but
at 28 it happened like it was it it was
undeniable that Wine Library was one of
the most successful independent wine
retailers in the country and I kind of
got into a group I built a good team I
didn't want to build a second store you
know I just had micro complacency and
then at 30. I started Wine Library TV
three months after 30 and that changed
the next 17 years of my career I would
say I had that complacency and nothing
happened and and I would argue that in
12 years I'll be doing this and I'll
explain how I had complacency the year
after covid who the heck knows that
complacency in the time
it was an app it was a in hindsight and
the reality is is there's no reason to
beat yourself up there's no reason to
hold yourself to a standard that doesn't
come natural there's no reason to create
an ideology of you being a superhero
when you're just a human being and I
think your framework is right you could
build the biggest augmented reality
company in the world if your parents
pass away and during that era and you
say wait a minute why didn't I go to
dinner with them once every two weeks or
nothing matters so you've got it you've
got it how to interaction with a guy
around gratitude and it was just like
very interesting I was just like yeah
once you go there you really actually
don't need anything else the Simplicity
of the Gratitude framework like if
you're just actually grateful for what
you have actually for the littlest
things versus envious for the [__] that
you don't have everything's just better
every single problem you have gets
better even the most extreme things like
are you grateful for the time you had
with somebody you loved you know that
kind of gratitude wins
[Music]
no I think it was just a I listened to
positive people around me I just limited
envy and jealousy and I leaned into
optimism and gratitude and I've been
practicing it for 40 years and here I am
humans are byproducts of the information
and the energy they decide to consume
this is why I would get so crazy just
about like people who want to like stay
in unhappiness if you're deeply unhappy
instead of blaming everyone else for it
put in the work to get out of it because
you can I believe in people I believe in
you like you can do it one can create
their luck by acknowledging right in
this minute as you watch this video or
listen to it on podcast that you're like
everyone has a moment that lady just now
earlier just before like I quit my job
before
you're like just do all the content I
was like yeah
thank you I'm proud of you thank you
I was there like I just heard you say it
do it and I was like it was my that that
was my time and we're all affected by
that I'm just one human there's lots of
people doing different versions of this
if you want to find positivity it's
everywhere there's just way too much
momentum right now of people looking for
a negativity what they're doing is
they're avoiding accountability it gets
really cozy to blame Perfection for not
doing oh you don't get it Julian I'm a
perfectionist that's why I can't put out
this video I'm a perfectionist no you're
not you're cute with your words and
you're using it as an excuse to not do
because you fear failure you're not a
perfectionist you're of an avoider
people just decided that everyone else's
life is perfect like you have no idea
what's going on in someone's head or
there are four walls behind their door
it's just not true all that energy to
judge others for their perfection or
what they did wrong it's all outward
what about putting it on yourself
everybody company is obsessed with Pac
platforms and culture what does that
mean it means that every single person
in our agency has to know what every
platform is doing every day we have
literally hundreds and hundreds of
people every day obsessed about every
single thing every platform is doing at
the moment and then an entire different
group
yet one in the same sometimes if they
have enough Talent that's paying
attention to culture which rappers which
athletes which soda which fashion brand
which everything what is happening in
culture and not just youth culture what
are moms in Indonesia care about what
are people in Afghanistan consuming like
literally global
information on both platform and culture
and once that is at your obsession and
your ideas come from the framework of
pack
your ideas will do better you will get
more Quant and quality back from that
and that will create a collective wisdom
of what you should be doing or what is
touching the hearts and the minds
because the only way someone does
something
votes for someone
buys something goes somewhere is when
that thing hits someone's relevance
inside of them and led them to consider
something marketing hasn't changed in a
long time
the mediums and the creative strategies
change
and the industry is holding on to
yesterday for dear life
and I am intrigued by tomorrow
I'm intrigued by tomorrow this industry
is obsessed with yesterday but I and my
companies we've dominated today
tomorrow's interesting and we'll keep an
eye on it because it's coming yesterday
is a nice romantic story but it's the
easiest waste of money of all time it's
today
that we focus on and I think that's what
our relationship focusing on there was a
kid who wrote a medium piece about me
being the face of hustle porn which to
this day lingers
and it was a medium article I was on a
plane I landed and it was just all this
chaos and there was a lot of things that
weren't true like me I didn't inherit my
dad's liquor store I built my dad's
store for him
there were some things that really like
trigger me that one always hurts because
I think I did one of the most noble acts
a human with Talent can do I knew at 17
that I was a guy
and I decided consciously
that I loved my parents so much that I
was going to dedicate a decade of my
youth Prime fierce
Pro 20 to 30 is fine you got time you
got energy you got I gave 10 of my
greatest years they're not my wisdom
years but they're my
years and I gave them gave them to my
parents
never made over 120 000 a year built a
business from 3 to 65 million left with
nothing started vaynermedia in Mike
Lazaro's conference room at buddy media
at 34 years old because I had no money
I'm proud of that so when you can
imagine when somebody writes a hit piece
and says you can't listen to this guy he
inherited
his dad's liquor store that hurts when
you say hurts what are the symptoms of
that hurt for you oh you're gonna love
this because this is why it's not
sustainable I'm
I'm
neutral
at all times
Gary you're the goat thank you Gary
you're I understand
why does it hurt I know that there is
millions of 15 to 25 year olds 30 to 60
year olds 61 to 90 year olds right now
who've decided not to consume my message
because one person who's hurting decided
to build themselves up by targeting me
because of the platform I'm on and that
disappoints me more than anything as
someone who is deeply deeply deeply
driven by leaving the impact at the
highest levels that he is capable of out
of the guilt and gratitude of winning
the DNA and environment game the
elimination of opportunity to help make
the world more about love
in lieu of someone reinforcing their
beliefs of living the world of dark and
hate
is crushing for me philosophically
but the reason it's not sustained Steve
is my number one fan on Earth
outside of my family whoever that is
Sally Pants McGee and my number one
person that hates me the most thinks
that the whole thing is the worst can't
wait till I die I equally feel the same
about it zero how do you prevent
yourself from you know like getting
burnt down from it all what do you do to
kind of like keep the pace with all this
stuff
I love myself
let me explain
I don't judge myself when I don't feel
like I've got it all grasped
you're absolutely right they're just
moving super fast
it's okay to not be great at knowing how
Snapchat works it's all right if you've
never downloaded Pinterest it's cool if
you have no clue what the [__] going
on on LinkedIn
you just keep trying every day
I think the biggest reason I don't get
burnt out is because I don't beat myself
up
by far one of the biggest issues that so
many people have young old Left Right
black white is
people beat themselves up
and by the way do not get it twisted I'm
not talking about not holding yourself
up to a standard
but
it's just a little patience
back to the earlier question I've been
doing this every day for 17 years
I'm good at it now
some of you have never thought about
these Platforms in this context prior to
when you started here
you were using it to hook up
you know so like you know I just have
empathy for yourself
right that's how you try you try and you
realize like and I think you sense it
here like we have ambition we're
building a honey Empire but like
we're gonna give you a lot of time as
long as you're trying you know for me my
employees are my family I think we have
audacity
at the ownership level at the leadership
level the way I think about getting team
members on board is by caring more about
their needs than mine the way I do it is
through empathy and compassion and
putting myself in their shoes and asking
why would they want to be on board I
reverse engineered their emotional graph
and then on an individual basis
I try to understand where they are on
their Journey
sometimes kids come into my company and
the first time I sit down with them they
say to me one day I'm going to run this
whole company and I'm thrilled I'm like
please I'm getting old you know
that same employee five years later
sometimes walks into my office and says
I need more work-life balance because
now they fell in love and they're
starting a different chapter of their
life and I love that I don't judge them
for not wanting to work 14 hours a day
anymore I respect that that's their
interest I think it's a Leader's
obligation to reverse engineer the wants
and needs of the people on their team
not only philosophically but in reality
on a day-to-day basis
and I think that's a very
very hard thing to do but I think it's
required to build something big
when you have the intent to care you ask
the questions
you know when people come up with
excuses of why they haven't accomplished
something it's often predicated on the
fact that they didn't want to know the
answer at the time
this is why everyone struggles the thing
that everybody wants can only be
achieved when it's earned you haven't
done anything
too many people think fake it to you
make it is real
even if they don't think of it that way
they think of it the nice way the way
you're doing this is very important I'm
really happy right now this is something
I haven't been able to dig into as much
as I want which is why I was so ready
with it's earned I've been thinking a
lot about it
but you're not an expert
but who is an expert and why should you
even try to be an expert
I don't necessarily I never thought for
one day that I was a marketing expert or
Guru or genius
I just was executing every day and then
talking about what I was executing and
then they decided more than me
you're trying to get them to believe
that in you for your own self-interest
but you haven't done anything for them
yet
more importantly why can't you just be
an enthusiast
I think everyone is so convinced that
the money
is an expertise
and I actually think it's in the
enthusiast
and I think just by changing that word
Everything Changes
you're not going to trick them Gary
I don't give a [__] what you did about
those seven videos
you're not gonna trick me but you don't
have to
I don't want to that's the thing well
you do want to you don't want to trick
them but you want them to think you're
an expert
I mean I want to do the you know a
business online I understand
that's why you're vulnerable if you want
to be upset about the world good news
turn on the television open your phone
and go on social media and you will be
upset 24 7. on the flip side
if you want to be happy
and optimistic good news turn on the
television and take out your phone and
you can be really optimistic and happy
you're deciding what you're looking at
not the algorithm
you up
and so I'm very passionate about that
some people are more naturally gifted
some people in this room were born with
a chest it's just the way it is but can
every person make strides in a direction
of being better at anything the answer
is yes I think it's cool to get better
at basketball I think it's cool to get
better at singing I think it's cool to
get better at skiing I think it's cool
to get better at cooking but all of that
is dog compared to getting better at
being optimistic and happy versus
pessimistic and sad and so watching
people like Dustin watching basically
every person I've been around since I
was six years old if they spend enough
time with me or people that look like me
watching watching my own father being
wildly affected by his 14 16 18 20 year
old son and move from Deep
done to a neutral or 80 better has been
one of the great joys of my life and so
what I used to do for people around me
and now I do at scale it's very
enjoyable it's the best feeling on Earth
nothing feels better than making
someone's life better there's a million
ways to do it but I believe changing
someone's perspective because it is
completely moldable
a perspective is completely moldable
changing someone's perspective to
realizing and it's what he does I can't
believe Dustin went there and he knows
this maybe he subconsciously went there
he knows because he knows me a lot like
drock used to people say to me all the
time Gary you don't get it I just keep
it real I'm like real negative
you don't keep it real what's real you
decide it's broken I decide it's good
who's keeping it real keeping it real is
[__] there's no realism there is no
real
life is how you see it it's too complex
the audacity of a human thinking they've
got it mapped on the record I do not
believe I am right about anything
I believe it's just how I see it
I know one thing I'm 47 and I've dealt
with a ton of [__] in my life and when I
think about my percentage of happiness
and lack of anxiety compared to the
enormous amount of human beings I've
gotten to know in my lifetime I will
take mine every day of the week and I'm
very affected by that especially when I
have real life examples in front of my
face like Dustin and the thousands of
other people that I've interacted with
in my life deeply and the tens of
thousands that I've interacted with if
not hundreds of thousands virtually this
is simple it's black and white we must
fight for happiness where are you
finding the most meaning in your
Pursuits
oh disproportionately in the garyvee of
it all like
the Gary B content thing like looking at
these young faces and knowing that some
of them think I'm cool thus giving me
leverage and equity for them to listen
to me so that I can tell them that
kindness and patience and humility and
being a sweet person is actually the
winning formula is massive
you know when I get the feedback from
people that you changed my life because
I realized I didn't have to be a face
and I'm not a face Gary I'm not a face
but I thought you had to be a face to
win the game right like to me that is
profound
and you know I think for the people here
who like skew towards being a guidance
counselor or like a camp counselor or
like a head coach or you know this will
make sense to them because I have this
in me when you get your joy from other
people getting Joy from your actions
there's no better Joy
it's just that what's I think a little
bit unique about me if I'm like
analyzing myself as if I'm not myself is
that has come in like spiritual leaders
that's come in like parenting that's
common guidance counselors and
principles and
it just we haven't heard that from like
gangster ass business people
you know like I think that's what's
probably you know as I analyze it I'm
like why the [__] is this happening I'm
like you know that's right like I can't
think of somebody who like is crushing
out here in that way
that's also spewing grandma
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Alex hermosi inspiration
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there priorities mean
two things cannot be equally important
when you work on something if I spend 30
minutes on both things and I say this
one's more important than this one I can
say that but that's not reality